Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 166. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, heute habe ich mal wieder was ganz spezielles für euch. Ein unerwartetes Thema, auch für mich ein bisschen unerwartet, bin das vor kurzem drauf gekommen, das mal zu machen, weil sich mal wieder die Gelegenheit geboten hat. Heute wollen wir in See stechen und uns in die unendlichen Weiten der Meere begeben, kurz gesagt es geht ums Segeln oder sagen wir mal vielleicht ein bisschen mehr auch so eher das Befahren der Meere und das Ganze auch noch mit so einer speziellen Geek-Perspektive. Und dazu begrüße ich Jung.
Hallo Tim.
Oder auch Jens-Uwe Mager. Hallo, du bist mal wieder in Deutschland, das ist gut. Das letzte Mal als wir die Gelegenheit hatten, haben wir auch gleich ein Podcast aufgenommen. Da allerdings so Sachen, die dich eigentlich auch schon seit langem nicht mehr so richtig beschäftigen. Das war Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 97, knapp zwei Jahre her. Da ging es um Fallsharing und Printsharing und so. Das ist ja deine alte Stärke. Ja, jetzt hast du deine Stärken so ein bisschen woanders hin verlagert und nutzt eigentlich den Großteil der Zeit mit Reisen, kann man so sagen.
Ja, ich bin auf Dauerreise. Auf Dauerreise, genau. Also im Wesentlichen wohne ich jetzt auf dem Boot, auf dem Seegeboot und befahre die Weltmeere. Aktueller Status, Kolumbien.
Kolumbien, das heißt, das schunkelt also so ein bisschen. Natürlich jetzt gerade nicht. Bahnkart 100 reicht auch noch nicht bis Kolumbien. Aber da liegt das Boot jetzt sozusagen.
Das Boot liegt jetzt, also eigentlich liegt es nicht, sondern es steht an Land. Es ist mal für die Zeit der Abwesenheit sicher an Land gestellt und wird dann wieder ins Wasser gekommen mit einem Kran, wenn ich zurück bin.
Weil man weiß ja gar nicht, was da alles so kommen kann.
Genau, es ist ein bisschen unsicher. Und es ist einfacher, das in einem Bootjahrt an Land zu stellen. Da sind große Hunde drum herum, keiner klaut was.
Okay, und da zahlt man dann sozusagen so eine Flat-Fee und dann steht das da so rum?
Genau, ein monatlicher Obolus, den man bezahlen muss für Wachhunde und so weiter, dass da nichts passiert und dass man dann den Parkplatz an Land hat.
Wie bist du da überhaupt auf die Idee gekommen? Ich meine, du bist ja nicht so ein altes Seglerherz, oder?
Nee, ich habe also gesegelt während der Zeit, wo ich gearbeitet habe intensiv hier, immer an Tastatur und Bildschirm gesessen, nur in Ferien, mal eine Woche irgendwo hingefahren, Boot gemietet mit Freunden zusammen. Und dann später habe ich mich dann überlegt, dass so man müsste noch mal was machen, wo man mehr draußen ist. Und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass ich jetzt seit 2005 mehr Zeit im Jahr auf dem Wasser verbringe, als irgendwie an Land.
Und was ist das jetzt für ein Boot? Wie muss man sich das so vorstellen?
Das ist also ein Boot in der Länge. Boote werden dann noch in Füßen gemessen. Gibt es ganz klassisch die Maßeinheit in Fuß. Das ist 40 Fuß lang. Also 12,40 Meter ungefähr, die Länge. Und 3,85 Meter breit, 2 Meter Tiefgang, ein Mast, ein großes Segel, den Mast hoch nach hinten, das Großsegel. Und vorne Vorsiegel, verschiedene, aber Rollsegel in der Fall. Man ist ja heutzutage etwas bequem. Man fährt mit kleiner Crew, bei uns also genau gesagt zwei Leute, weil wir permanent auf dem Boot sind. Und da muss man ein bisschen Bequemlichkeit haben. Und da wird also schon einiges beim Boot heutzutage auch elektrisch bedient. Also man kurbelt nicht mehr so viel. Ich habe also auch elektrische Wünsche, auf den Knopfdruck das Seil festgezogen und so was. Man kann natürlich immer noch mechanisch, aber für den Normalfall macht man es elektrisch.
Ist das jetzt, ich meine, Boot gibt es in allen Größen, Formen und Farben. Aber jetzt sagen wir mal so für so ein Segelboot, was man so mit zwei Leuten, also braucht man auch immer beide?
Nein. Also das war eigentlich eine der Auswahlkriterien. Das ist ein Boot, das ich auch alleine segeln kann. Und 2005 bin ich auch rund England gesegelt, alleine einhändig, man das so schön nennt. Und das ist problemlos möglich.
Aber zwölf Meter ist ja schon ein ganz schöner Klopper eigentlich.
Zwölf Tonnen.
Zwölf Tonnen?
Zwölf Tonnen wiegt das gute Stück. Beladen, also zehn Tonnen leer, zwölf Tonnen mit ungefähr 460 Liter Diesel, 460 Liter Wasser, die drin sein können. Und das, was man so zulädt, kommt so auf zwölf Tonnen, Pima Dorm.
Futter und man selbst und so weiter. Genau. Und ist das also, aber so für eine Person ist das schon ein recht großes Schiff, oder?
Für eine Person ist es recht groß. Aber es ist von der Größe her auch gerade so, dass man sagen kann, das Boot ist ozeangehend, tauglich überall auf der Welt.
Ja.
Du kannst also über den Atlantik fahren, über den Pazifik mitfahren. 40 Fuß ist eine schöne Größe.
Und wo würde diese Ozeangängigkeit anfangen? Also, was müsste man schon so mindestens an Länge oder Gewicht?
Da gibt es eigentlich keine kleinste Größe. Es gibt eine Bequemlichkeitsstufe. Es gibt Leute, die segeln mit ganz kleinen Segelbooten, die du eigentlich nur auf den See erwarten würdest. Segel über den Atlantik. Da gibt es diese berühmten Transatrennen, wo Leute irgendwo von Nordfrankreich nach Brasilien mit sechs Meter panzerquetschte Booten fahren, die du eigentlich sonst erwarten würdest. Die würden uns auf den großen See fahren.
Sechs Meter?
Sechs Meter fünfzig. Das glaube ich.
Das ist auch schon ein paar Meter groß. Aber gut, man muss ja auch reinpassen, man muss ja auch drin schlafen können.
Ja, da habe ich also auch schon Boote gesehen, die sind eher aus wie ein kleiner Sarg. Das heißt, ich habe so einen Studenten aus Schweden gesehen, da habe ich den Sankt Lucia in der Karibik gesehen, da habe ich das Boot angeguckt, gedacht, da siehst du drin, da liegt er wie ein Sarg. Aber das war eben halt seine Bootsbau-Lehrling. Da meinte, macht man eine Pause.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Äquivalent zu diesem Schlafsackgroßen-Treffeler-Zelt, was man auch so gerade mal so über sich rübergezogen bekommt. Das habe ich auch immer nicht so richtig verstanden.
Aber es ist eben halt sehr, sehr rustikal dann und 40 Fuß hat eine gewisse Komfortabilität und eine gewisse Eigenschaften beim Segeln mit dem Gewicht, mit der Größe, mit dem Verhalten in den Wellen. Das ist eine recht komfortable Größe.
Das heißt, da wird man nicht so durchgeschüttelt. Das ist nicht so Ocean in a nutshell, sondern das flügt auch schon mal durchs Wasser.
Genau. Umso größer, umso länger, umso schneller werden die Boote. Da gibt es ja diese alte Regel, die Segelboote fahren in Verdrängerfahrt. Es gibt Gleitfahrt und Verdrängerfahrt. Gleitfahrt ist das, wenn man sehr viel Antriebskraft hat und das Boot erhebt sich so aus dem Wasser und wird vorgetrieben, hat benetzt dann sehr, sehr wenig Wasser und hat eigentlich hinten noch ein kleines Stückchen vom Rumpf im Wasser und die Schrauben. Die schnellen Motorboote benutzen Gleitfahrt. Oder so ein kleines, schnelles Ding.
Hebt sich eigentlich weitgehend raus und hat wenig Berührung.
Und wenn du also ein normales Segelboot nimmst, dann fährt das in Verdrängerfahrt, wie zum Beispiel auch ein ganz normaler großer Frachter. Und dann hast du ein System, bestehend aus Bugwelle und Heckwelle, die beschränken deine Geschwindigkeit und die ist abhängig von der Länge. Es ist meistens ziemlich irrelevant, wie viel Antriebskraft du hast. Solange du nicht in Gleitfahrt gehst, dich rausbehebst mit enormem Treibstoffaufwand, bewegst du dich an einem gefangenen System zwischen Bugwelle und Heckwelle, die deine Maximalgeschwindigkeit vorgibt anhand der Länge des Bootes.
Ach so, und das heißt, umso länger das Boot ist, umso schneller ist es?
Umso schneller kann es fahren. Das ist, muss ich jetzt die Strömungsmechaniker fragen. Aber ich kenne alte Vorsträge, die man beim Segeln lernt. Und wenn ich bei mir ausrechne, die 40 Fuß kommen auf ungefähr maximal 8,1 Knoten, Maximalgeschwindigkeit.
8,1 Knoten sind?
Ein Knoten sind eine Seemeile pro Stunde.
Das ist so 1,8 oder so, ne?
Du weißt noch, wo die Seemeile herkommt?
Das wusste ich mal.
Ja, eine Seemeile ist also ein Sechzigstelgrad. Also 60 Seemeilen sind ein Grad, wenn man also das Gitternetz auf der Erde guckt.
Macht Sinn.
Macht Sinn, ne? Also 1,8 Kilometer ungefähr pro Stunde mal 8,1. Bei mir ist das die Maximalgeschwindigkeit, die Umfgeschwindigkeit, die ich erreichen kann mit dem Boot. Geht natürlich auch ein bisschen schneller, wenn man zum Beispiel in der Welle runtersurft. Aber maximal ist so Pi mal Däum 8.
Also 8,1 mal 1,8 sozusagen.
Ja.
15 km Strecke, ein bisschen weniger.
Das ist ein langsamer Fahrradfahrer. Das ist sehr gemütlich. Hat den Vorteil, du hast niemals Jetlag, auch wenn du längere Touren machst.
Okay, das heißt, das Boot muss lang sein und umso länger es ist, umso schneller wird es.
Kann es auch fahren. Kann es fahren. Es hängt natürlich noch mal an, welche Vortriebsmöglichkeiten es hat. Aber das System aus Bugwelle und Heckwelle ermöglicht eine größere Endgeschwindigkeit physikalisch.
Also das hat sozusagen was mit Verwirbelung zu tun. Also umso näher die aneinander dran sind, umso mehr zieht sich das sozusagen an der See fest.
Exakt. Das ist das Problem. Und natürlich auch die Bequemlichkeit steigt mit einer größeren Länge, weil dann durch die Wellen nicht mehr so stark mitgenommen wird. Wenn man so kleine kurze, steile Wellen hat, wie in der Ostsee, dann ist ein längeres Boot einfach schöner, weil das gar nicht mitmacht. Das ganze Boot liegt ruhiger. Und so längere Boote erzeugen einen höheren Komfort. Schneller und höheren Komfort.
Gut. 40 Fuß. Aber es sieht so aus, wie man sich so ein Segelboot so vorstellt.
Genau. Typisches Segelboot, großen Mast. Ein Mast, einer nur. 18,50 Meter hoch.
18,50 Meter hoch.
Das ist ganz interessant, wie man das hochklettern muss.
Also es ist höher als lang, sozusagen.
Ja. Es ist interessant, wie man da hochklettern muss.
Muss man da hochklettern?
Ja, gelegentlich muss man ja schließlich gucken, was da so oben ist, ob die ganzen Drahtseile, ob die anderen tau, ob die noch in Ordnung sind. Muss man gelegentlich mal eine Glühbirne wechseln, für irgendwelche Beleuchtungszwecke. Also man muss da schon mal gelegentlich hoch.
Weil man da Lampen dran hat, damit man auch mal gesehen wird, sozusagen.
Genau.
Und dann ist es ganz schön hoch. Schwankt das da nicht irgendwie so ganz wüsst hin und her?
Das schwankt schon ganz schön. Also wenn man vor Anker liegt, also ich bin schon vor Anker hoch da gewesen. Und wo dann also noch gehöriger Seegang da war in der Bucht. Und dann ist das da oben schon ein bisschen so, dass man sich da festhält am Macht, damit man nicht so gegendängelt.
Aber du machst das nur, wenn du auf Anker bist.
Ja, ich habe es noch nicht gemacht. Ich habe noch keinen Notfall gehabt, dass ich oben in Mast müsste, während ich unterwegs war. Das könnte auch passieren, aber habe ich bisher vermieden.
Und hast du dann auch bergmanstaugliche Sicherungen?
Das macht man mit dem Ding, das heißt Bootsmannstuhl. Man zieht sich dann hoch anhand einer von den Seilen, die da drin sind, die Fallen, wie man sie nennt. Das sind die, die hoch und runter ziehen. Also eines der Fallen kann man sich dann hochziehen lassen über eine Winch. Sitz in so einem Stuhl drin, der mit so einem Gurt ist. Also mit Winch meinst du so eine... Mit Winch ist also generell dieses Ding, was man so kurbelt.
Einfach so eine Seilkurbel.
Genau, mit mehreren Gängen, meistens so zwei Gängen Winch, dass man mit langsam drehen und schnell drehen zwei Gänge hat.
Und der Bootsmannstuhl ist dann so ein Seil, was man unterm Arsch durchlaufen lässt, dann zieht man sich hoch.
Das ist meistens ein Sitz. Also bei mir ist es so mit richtig so ein kleiner Sitz, der geformt ist, und so ein kleines bisschen Sperrholz drin, dass man also bequem sitzt und nochmal um die Beine festgeschnallt, dass man nicht rausfallen kann da oben, dass man so halbwegs sicher sitzt. Das ist so eins von den elementaren Werkzeugen, dass jedes Segelboot dazugehört. Also einen Bootsmannstuhl braucht.
Nee, also zumindest nicht, dass ich jetzt mal so mit einem gefahren wäre. Jaja, wahrscheinlich. Na, erst mal hören, was du noch für so gefahren lauernd. Okay, das heißt, da kann man sich irgendwie so hochziehen, dann muss man da irgendwie hoch und dann ist irgendwie hoch.
Ist sehr hoch, also man darf da keine Höhenangst sagen. Aber das ist ja nur Maintenance, das ist ja nicht für einen Normalfall. Im Normalfall bist du unten im Cockpit. Und mein Boot ist dann auch eine Variante, das nennt sich Center Cockpit-Boot, weil das Cockpit in der Mitte ist, mit einer Achter-Kajüte, also in dem Zentralen Talon und einer Vorder-Kajüte. Aber es gibt Boote, die haben das Cockpit sehr weit hinten. Achter Cockpit-Boote, oder wir haben hier im Zentrum Center Cockpit-Boote. Und Center Cockpit-Boote haben meist eine Eigenschaft, dass sie ein relativ kleineres Cockpit haben, weil es in der Mitte etwas kompakter ist. Und wo man relativ gut geschützt ist von überkommenden Wellen und dergleichen. Sozusagen ein ganz anheimliches... Also bist schon drin sozusagen.
Also stehst du ja jetzt nicht so hinten auf dem Heck, so mit so einem Steuerrad in der Hand und immer so die Gischt im Maul.
Genau, genau.
So ist es nicht.
Aber wenn es dann regnet, brauchst du keine Taucherbrille.
Aber geht natürlich so ein bisschen, geht dieses Piraten-Feeling so ein bisschen weg, oder?
Ja, man kann aber jetzt dieses, was nach vorne einen Schutz gibt für Wellen, das kann man auch ein bisschen runterklappen. Und wenn man dann möchte, kann man auch am Steuer stehen und wirklich das richtige Regatta-Feeling bekommen. Aber ich bin jetzt nicht der Regatta-Segler. Bei mir ist das mehr so das Ziel des Reisens.
Der Weg ist das Ziel?
Genau. Und das heißt, auch bei mir ist der Autopilot derjenige, der am meisten steuert. Also ich selber steuere eigentlich nur, oder eine Frau steuert eigentlich nur, wenn irgendwie Hafengebiete sind, oder wenn man sich in engen Bereichen aufhält, wo man nicht den Autopiloten steuern lassen kann.
Okay, ganz modern. Und wie viele Leute würden so draufpassen eigentlich auf das Boot?
Auf dem Boot gehen komfortabel vier Personen, ein bisschen kompakter fünf Personen, das ist das Maximum.
Okay, aber die haben dann auch irgendwie auch ihr eigenes Bett und so. Das heißt, du bist auch besuchstauglich und kannst mal Anhalter mitnehmen und so, falls man irgendwo rumsteht auf einer Insta oder so.
Das ist nicht ganz einfach mit Anhaltern mitnehmen.
Wegen der Anhalter?
Nee, wegen der entsprechenden Bestimmungen auf den jeweiligen Zielhäfen. Das wird gerne ein Dokument geprüft, das nennt sich Clearance Paper oder Zarpe in lateinamerikanischen Ländern, wo drinnen steht, im Abfahrthafen, welche Passnummern, welche Leute an Bord sind, beim Zielhafen, welche Leute sind an Bord und welche Passnummern haben die. Wenn da Unstimmigkeiten sind, also wenn man jemanden erdrängt hat und die auf dem unterwegs verloren hat oder jemanden dazugekommen hat, dann bekommt man da also schon Probleme mit den Leuten.
Nicht, dass du da irgendwie so einen Selbstmörder einfängst, der einfach so tschüss, ich geh dann mal mitten im Ozean.
Ja, das wäre ungünstig. Also normalerweise fährt man eigentlich nur mit Leuten, die man ein bisschen kennt.
Ja, ich hatte ja hier letztes Jahr, auch genau vor dem Jahr, habe ich eine Sendung gemacht über Piraten. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die schon gehört hast.
Noch nicht, die ist noch mal in der Liste.
Da geht es eigentlich auch viel um Karibik. Also die richtigen Piraten. CRE 133 mit dem Roland aus Wien, das war ganz lustig. Der hat sich da irgendwie intensiv mit beschäftigt. Aber so in der Karibik ist das gerade nicht so ein Thema, oder? Also so aktuell?
Doch, es gibt Piratenbereiche. Also es gibt Gebiete, die generell von Deglern, von Krösern, wie man sie so nennen, nicht so gern befahren werden. Das ist zum Beispiel auch Venezuela. Venezuela ist ein sehr gefährliches Gebiet im Montan. Der Bereich zwischen Venezuela und Kolumbien ist zum Teil sehr gefährlich. Sollte man aufpassen, wenn man da lang segelt. Wird sehr gerne überfallen. Boote werden von schnellen Schlauchbooten überfallen, ausgeraubt und dergleichen. Ist ein gefährliches Gebiet der Erde.
Ist ja aber noch nicht passiert.
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Aber du bist ja gerade jetzt in der Gegend.
Ja, ich bin momentan in Katargena, in Kolumbien. Das ist also aber erreicht im Direktsegeln vom Norden her, von Jamaika aus. Ich bin also jetzt die letzte Tour, die ich gemacht habe, über Jamaika, Kolumbien gesegelt.
Ja, da hast du sozusagen Venezuela übersprungen.
Venezuela habe ich übersprungen. Vor zwei Jahren waren wir in Trinidad, Tobago, in der Nähe von Venezuela. Und da hatten wir uns dann aber nicht entschlossen, nach Venezuela zu fahren, einfach wegen der gefährlichen Situation. Da kam dann ein anderes Segelboot an, das hatte Einschusslöcher im Rumpf von Waffen. Und das war dann unattraktiv für uns geworden. Da haben wir uns entschieden, nach Noron zu segeln.
Unattraktiv, ja. Kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Das ist sicherlich kein Spaß so. Man hat ja auch eine Menge zu verlieren, wenn man da irgendwie so...
Ja, ist ja alles an Bord. Das muss man sich vorstellen wie im Wohnwagen. Du hast ja Klamotten an Bord, du hast so eine Spielzeuge an Bord. Nicht unhebliche Investitionen an irgendwelchen Gerätschaften. Und das möchtest du nicht verlieren.
Na klar. Aber grundsätzlich ist man natürlich da andererseits, wenn man jetzt mal von den Piratenbedrohungen absieht, also so Verkehrsunfälle etc., das ist ja jetzt nicht so ein großes Problem.
Das könnte ein Problem sein.
Also ein Hafen vielleicht, oder?
Im Hafen gibt es diese Sache mit dem sogenannten Hafenbilliard, wie wir das nennen. Ich könnte es mir schon fast vorstellen.
Schlecht verteutes Gerät oder was.
Genau, das kann es immer mal passieren, dass entweder jemand, der Anker dreckt, wenn man einen sehr engen Bereich hat, wo viele Boote ankern, dann kommt ein Gewitter mit starken Böen, und dann hält der Anker doch nicht, wie gewünscht, so fest, wie man es gerne hat. Dann bewegt sich das Boot langsam in die Richtung von anderen Booten. Die anderen Booten holen schon ihre Fender raus und versuchen dann...
Ihre was?
Fender. Fender sind diese Puschel an der Seite, die großen, aufgepumpten Kunststoffwürste oder Bälle, die dazu dienen, dass man, wenn man gegen einen Steg fährt, dass man dort...
Stoßstangen sozusagen.
Stoßstangen, genau. Die werden rausgehängt, die werden in den Seezaun gehängt und werden dann im Hafen verwendet, wenn man irgendwo an einer Tankstelle anlegt oder wirklich in einem Liegeplatz, wo das Boot dann liegen kann, länger Zeit. Oder wenn man vor Anker ist, dann holt man die dann raus, wenn ein anderes Boot langsam anfängt zu driften. Man glaubt, das könnte vielleicht zu nahe kommen. Es gibt immer wieder die Situation.
Okay, verstehe. Aber wenn man erstmal so draußen ist, dann ist das ja jetzt nicht so...
Man muss immer aufpassen. Also was wir machen, wir müssen wieder nachts segeln. Dann wird also dann Nachtwachen eingeteilt, dass immer jemand oben an Deck ist und auch Aussicht halten kann. Weil ich hab also auch schon... Immer. Bis auf kleine Pausen, wenn man aufs Klo geht oder so. Aber das ist ja nicht so... Es ist nicht so wichtig, dass jeder Minute jemand guckt.
Aber ihr bleibt jetzt nicht einfach mal so nachts stehen und schlaft und wacht dann auf?
Nein, das macht man meist nicht. Auch wegen dem Seegang ist es eigentlich nicht angebracht, mit dem Boot einfach anzuhalten. Man lässt das weiter segeln. Das Ganze wird instabil und das bewegt sich sehr stark.
Autopilot einfach so laufen lassen, wäre jetzt auch nicht so angesagt.
Man lässt ihn laufen, man ist aber an Bord und man hört zum Beispiel Tims Podcast mit dem Kopfhörer. Und beobachtet gelegentlich mal so alle 10 Minuten, macht man mal so einen Umblick, alle 5-10 Minuten guckt man sich mal um und guckt, welche Boote in die Nähe kommen. Also ich habe schon erlebt, mitten in der Karibik kommt dann ein Frachter einem entgegen und der hat einen anscheinend nicht gesehen, weil der hat auch alle Radargeräte ausgeschaltet. Der fährt einfach auf Autopilot. Ich weiß nicht, die Crew guckt gerade Fußball oder was auch immer die gerade tun. Und die interessieren sich nicht. Und es ist ja auch an der Stelle, die sind aus massiv Stahl groß und wir sind ein kleiner Plastik-Joghurtbecher. Und Joghurtbecher auf Stahl, das hören die nicht mal hinten, wenn da vorne was knallt.
Da sieht man dann nur noch beim Absaufen hinten so das große Schild We Break For Nobody.
Ich glaube, das hängt natürlich ab, wo die herkommen oder was die tun. Ein großes Kreuzfahrtschiff mit voller Crew wird da schon nicht immer jemanden haben.
Ist denn da viel Verkehr? Du bist ja auch über den Atlantik gereist. Da würde ich mir schon denken, dass man da auch mal einen Tag niemanden sieht.
Da sieht man etliche Tage nichts. Da sind wir gefahren, ja, die Route von den Kanarischen Inseln Richtung Kapwerdeinseln noch ein bisschen südlicher und dann von Kapwerdeinseln direkt westlich in die Karibik rüber und dort begegte man so gut wie Keimen. Also wir hatten den Effekt, dass wir die ganze Überfahrt über 18 Tage lief. Also hat von den Kanarischen Inseln bis nach Barbados 18 Tage gedauert. Und wir haben kurz bevor wir nach Westen abgeknickt sind, also erst noch ein bisschen südlich von den Kanarischen Inseln, dann als wir westlich abgeknickt sind, haben wir letzten Dampfer gesehen, der zwischen Kanarischen Inseln und Kapwerde hier und her gefahren ist, bis wir das erste Fischerboot ungefähr einen Tag gesehen haben, bevor wir nach Barbados angekommen sind. Also es waren fast 16 Tage nichts gesehen.
Aber trotzdem war immer jemand da und hat geguckt.
Also wir haben immer geguckt. Sicherheitshalber. Aber wir haben niemanden gesehen. Es war nichts da. Außer Vögel oder gelegentlich mal. Man sieht mal Define irgendwo.
Wie fühlt man sich dann so?
Es ist ein ganz eigenes Gefühl. Es ist gemischt. Manche Leute finden das entsetzlich. Andere Leute finden das wunderbar, weil im Einklang mit Natur, man hört nur Rauschen von Wellen und Wind und man ist ganz alleine. Es ist also sehr schön in der Stelle, aber auch ein bisschen langweilig. Also ich habe nach der Überfahrt ein Buch vor Ort ausgelesen gehabt. Also ich war da so ziemlich...
Ist ja auch mal gut.
Ist auch gut. Aber es ist eine ganz coolige Sache. Man ist ganz in seinem Trott drin. Also ich glaube, das wichtigste Thema ist was kochen die Leute zu Abend?
Ja, wobei die Auswahl steht ja eigentlich auch schon fest. Ist ja nicht so, dass man nochmal losgehen könnte zum nächsten Supermarkt.
Man muss dann schon richtig einkaufen. Also die Einkaufsaktion vor einem größeren Überfahrt, das ist schon ein bisschen stressend, das Ganze zu verstauen im Boot. Also Einkaufen im großen Stil. Viele, viele Einkaufswagen, viele Dosen. Man baut zwei kleine Kühlschränke, die mit 12 Volt betrieben werden. Eine ist davon auch als Gefrierfach umkonfigurierbar. Haben wir auf der Atlantik- Überfahrt tatsächlich als Gefrierschrank verwendet, um eingefrorenes Fleisch und andere eingefrorene Sachen zu haben.
Da kommen wir schon so langsam in Richtung Bordtechnik. Ich würde bloß gerne nochmal, bevor wir da jetzt so schnell abdriften, nochmal so ein bisschen verstehen, was man eigentlich tun muss, wenn man jetzt mal nicht den Autopilot benutzt. Also wie fährt denn so ein Teil eigentlich? Also wir hatten jetzt festgehalten, da ist ein Mast, da ist eigentlich ein großes Segel dran.
Das ist also zwei Segel da dran und zwar der Mast ist nach oben, der hat einen Vorstark, das ist das Drahtseil oder Aluminiumprofil, was vorne am Boot ist, was den Mast nach vorne hält, wo ein Vorsegel befestigt wird, was von vorne bis zum Mast oder ein bisschen überlappend, wenn das ein überlappendes Segel ist, ein Vorsegel ist und dann haben wir das Hauptsegel, was vom Mast hochgezogen, was nach hinten weg ist, mit dem Baum. Das vordere Segel hat keinen Baum, meistens nicht, auch wenn man es macht, wenn man es ausbaut. Also Baum ist der zusätzliche Mast. Vertikal der Mast und horizontal der Baum. Das Hauptsegel, das sogenannte Großsegel, von Mitte nach hinten, hat immer einen Baum, eigentlich mit einer aktuellen Segelkonfiguration, die man auf Sportsegeln findet. Und beide Segel zusammen, kannst du dir so vorstellen, wie ein Doppeldecker-Flügel nach oben gestellt. Und zwar, wenn du einen guten alten Doppeldeckler hast. Nee, ich rede von einem Flugzeug. Die Drahtflächen von einem Doppeldecker. Hast du so zwei Strömungshalter und dazwischen entsteht eine Luftströmung. Und die erzeugt bei einem Doppeldecker den Auftrieb. Generell nicht beim Doppeldecker, aber generell bei Flugzeugen. Und die Strömung um die Segel drumherum, also wenn man die horizontal aufgibt, das macht bei uns den Vortrieb bei Seglern. Was die Flugzeuge als Auftrieb benutzen, das benutzen wir als Vortrieb.
Das heißt, diese Krümmung, die in dem Flügel ist?
In den Segeln ist eine Krümmung drin. Und die beiden Segel zusammen mit dem Fluss der Luft durch diese beiden Segel durch, wie ein Doppeldecker de facto, ergibt bei uns, was bei einem Flugzeug den Auftrieb machen würde, bei uns den Vortrieb. Das ist ja die magische Sache. Wenn man ganz als Laie in das Segeln heran guckt, dann kann man eigentlich nur vorwärts segeln, wenn man den Wind von hinten hat. Das ist sozusagen die alte klassische Großseglertaktik, so wie Columbus gekommen ist. Der Kumpel muss den Wind von hinten haben. Das große quadratische Segel, die hochgezogen sind, da kann man ein bisschen mitjustieren, aber im Wesentlichen muss der Wind so ziemlich von hinten kommen.
Wenn er nicht kommt, dann geht es nicht vorwärts.
Dann hält man einen Anker und wartet, bis das Wetter sich dreht. Moderne Segelboote können bis nahezu scheinbarer Wind von 30 Grad bei Rennjachten und weniger mehr bei Krüserbooten, also bei solchen Segelbooten, die man so verwendet, um längere Zeit die Segel zu machen, die etwas bequemer sind, etwas breiter sind, die nicht so sehr für Rennen geschaffen worden sind. Dann macht man mal 35-38 Grad scheinbarer Windwinkel. Und dann ist das das Maximum, wo man fahren kann, gegen den Wind. Dabei ist es wichtig, nochmal zu unterscheiden, scheinbarer und echter Wind, was wir haben. Wind, wo er herkommt, plus Fahrtwind, ist der scheinbare Wind. In dem Moment, wo ich sozusagen den Wind nahezu von vorne habe, habe ich auch eine ganze Menge Wind, die durch meine Fahrt selber erstellt. Dadurch wird der Wind noch ein bisschen mehr nach vorne gedreht. Das ist der scheinbare Wind, den man misst. Deswegen sage ich von der Spitze her, 40 Grad ist bei guten Sportsegelbooten ein guter Wind, wenn du da an Wind fahren kannst. Wenn der Wind nahezu von vorne kommt und der Winkel zwischen der Nase vom Boot zu einem Wind, wo er wirklich herkommt, 40 Grad sind, wenn du das noch segeln kannst, hast du ein gutes Boot.
Eigentlich segelt man schon fast dem Wind entgegen.
Man muss bloß um 40 Grad mindestens schwenken. 40 Grad ist ein guter Wert, bequeme 60 Grad.
Und dann kommt der Wind von bequeme 60 Grad. Dann bleiben wir noch mal bei diesem bequemen 60 Grad. Ich segel quasi die Spitze des Bootes, zeigt 60 Grad gegen den tatsächlichen Wind oder den Scheinbandwind. Der ergibt sich aus meiner eigenen Geschwindigkeit.
Der Fahrtwind, den du erzeugst durch deine Fahrt und den Wind, den du wirklich hast.
Wenn ich jetzt erst mal stehe, dann habe ich ja keinen Fahrtwind.
Nee, aber den hast du ja hinterher die ganze Zeit.
Na gut, aber ich muss ja erst mal los.
Das ist aber egal. Der Wind dreht sich noch ein bisschen mehr nach vorne, wenn du fährst. Das ist der Effekt. Wenn du gegen den Wind fährst. Das kannst du normalerweise als Krüser eher seltener tust. Man versucht eigentlich den Wind immer möglichst weit von hinten zu haben, weil es bequemer ist. Das Boot macht, wenn du wirklich stark gegen den Wind segelst, so eine stampfende Bewegung, wo der Buch hoch und runter geht gegen die Wellen, die ist eigentlich eher unkomfortabel. Viele Segler, die das Segeln um das Reisenzwillen betreiben, nicht des Sportswegens, bevorzugen eher Windrichtungen, wo der Wind von der Seite kommt oder ein bisschen mehr von hinten.
Das macht man eigentlich nur, wenn man dringend in drei Tagen da sein muss.
Genau, wenn man wirklich irgendwo einen Termin hat oder wenn es nicht anders geht. Der Flug zurück. Ja, das ist schon wirklich so eine blöde Geschichte. Das sollte man nicht machen. Gibt es mal einen Spruch. Wenn man segelt, dann weiß man das Datum, wann man an einem Ort ist, aber nicht wo. Oder man weiß, wo man ist, aber nicht das Datum. Das ist nicht ganz so vorhersehbar, die ganze Geschichte. Also man kann jetzt nicht mit jemandem verabreden und sagen, du kommst jetzt an den Hafen so und so und dann nehme ich dich auf. Das geht nicht so einfach. Das funktioniert meist nicht.
Es kann gut sein, dass man ihn gar nicht erreicht.
Ja, man muss also dann immer noch flexibel sein. Setze dich mal da in den Bus und dann musst du noch mal so zwei Stunden im Bus fahren. Dann kommst du zu dem Hafen, wo ich es gerade hingeschafft habe. So nach der Methode.
So, aber jetzt nochmal mit dieser Segel-Dynamik, mit dem Vortrieb. Also wo jetzt der Wind auch immer... Also er kommt von irgendwo her.
Der Wind kommt von irgendwo her.
Vielleicht auch von hinten. Die Segel werden in irgendeiner Form auf jeden Fall so bauchig. Das müssen sie auch sozusagen. Oder können die auch einfach straff gerade sein?
Umso härter man am Wind fährt, also härter im Wind heißt es, umso mehr der Wind von vorne kommt, umso straffer zieht man sie. Bei Windrichtungen mehr von der Seite, dann werden sie mehr bauchiger gefahren. Das hängt von der Windrichtung ab. Und das kann man auch justieren mit den Tauen dort. Das hängt zum Beispiel an von der Spannung. Zum Beispiel das Großsegel. Je nachdem, wie das konfiguriert ist, kann man also bauchiger fahren, indem man also schwimmige Seile zieht, fester zieht oder Lose gibt. Und dann kann man also solche Sachen auch erzielen, dass man also diese Segel bauchiger hat. Und das macht man auch für verschiedene Windrichtungen. Wenn zum Beispiel der Wind von so einer Raumwindkurs ist, also Raumwind heißt, der Wind kommt so von der Seite, von hinten so ein bisschen. Vielleicht so im 120 Grad Bereich, immer von vorne gemessen, so an der Seite, nach Uhrzeit, vielleicht so von 4, 5 Uhr, 4 Uhr. Dann fährt man die Segel schon sehr bauchig, mehr bauchiger. Und wenn man dann ganz von hinten hat, so Plattformlaken, wie man es auch nennt unter Säglern, dann hat man natürlich die alte Taktik, dass man die Segel eigentlich als Vortriebmittel verwendet, weil sie von hinten von Sägel gefüllt wird. Und dann ist das eigentlich nicht mehr diese Tragflächenmechanik mehr.
Ach so, dann wird man tatsächlich einfach geschoben.
Genau, dann ist es nicht mehr die Tragflächenmimik. Also man hat eigentlich alle Varianten. Und die Segelboote von heute können eigentlich in allen Varianten gut fahren. Wobei die beste Geschwindigkeit eigentlich bei vielen Booten erzeugt wird, wenn sie so 90 Grad Wind haben. Dann sind sie am effizientesten.
Ach echt, von der Seite?
Von der Seite, das ist der effizienteste Wind. Das ist auch mein Boot am schnellsten.
Das heißt, wie muss man das vorstellen? Also ich will nach vorne, der Wind kommt von links. Oder man sagt, Lee oder was?
Nein, der Wind kommt immer von... Also Lee ist und Louv, das ist die alte Sache. Das kann man sich daran ganz gut merken. Lee ist die Seite, wo der Wind hinpustet und Louv wo der Wind herpustet.
Okay, also kommen tut er von Louv sozusagen. Okay, alles klar. So, das heißt, das drückt dann quasi direkt in meine Segel ein. So, jetzt mit so einem einfachen Denke, wenn wir ja sagen, okay, alles klar, der Wind kommt von der Seite, dann kippt das Boot einfach um, weil drückt ja oben gegen die Segel und dann kann es ja eigentlich nur ins Wasser fallen. Das passiert aber nicht, sondern...
Unten im Kiel sind große Bleigewichte. Segelboote haben normalerweise große Gegengewichte im Kiel. Zum Beispiel bei meinem Boot sind das 4,1 Tonnen Bleige, die da drin sind. Und die wirken als Kraft gegen den Wind. Das ist dieser Effekt, wo du siehst, wenn die Boote Schräglage haben, die Segel werden runtergedrückt ein bisschen, aber der Kiel geht als Gegengewicht. Und das Boot richtet sich auch wieder auf, wenn eine Böehe kommt und man hat zu viel Segel draußen, dann drückt der Wind das Boot mal ein bisschen runter und dann geht es wieder hoch, weil das Bleigewicht unten im Kiel dagegen ist.
Aber wie funktioniert das jetzt mit dem Vortrieb? Also wenn du jetzt auch sagst, das Boot funktioniert sogar optimal, wenn der Wind von der Seite kommt.
Dann wird das Segel rausgestellt. Das muss man sich so vorstellen. Den genauen Winkel kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen. Ich weiß, dass ich z.B. meinen Großsegel so weit öffne, dass der Baum in meinem Heckkorb zeigt, also hinten in die eine Ecke. Dann mache ich so meinen Segel auf für halber Wind. Halber Wind nennt man den Wind, der für den 90° von der Seite kommt. Dann wird das Großsegel weit aufgeöffnet, dass es in so einem Winkel von, ich weiß nicht, bis vielleicht 40° von vorne so steht. Dass es also so geöffnet ist.
Aber dann Richtung Leh.
Ja genau, Richtung Leh. Und beide Segel werden soweit geöffnet. Die werden so versucht, dass sie parallel stehen. Und dann fließt zwischen diesen beiden Segel so ein Strom durch von Luft, wo dann dieser Vortriebseffekt kommt, wie beim Doppeldecker beim Flugzeug ist. Aber der Vortrieb entsteht durch das, was beim Doppeldeckerflugzeug das Flugzeug nach oben hält. Dieser Strömungseffekt erzeugt dann einen Vortrieb, dass das Boot nach vorne zieht.
Toll! Tolle Technologie, oder?
Ja, es ist wunderbar.
Hat die Menschheit jetzt auch lang genug dran rumgeforscht? Wie lange wird gesegelt? 2000 Jahre? Länger.
Aber dass man wirklich diese Technik mit Vortrieb verwendet, also nicht diese quadratische Taktik. Das hat, glaube ich, gedauert, bis die Briten sich ein bisschen intensiver beschäftigt haben. Ich bin mir mit der Historie nicht ganz klar, aber war da echt ein großer Vorteil, als die britische Armee mal gegen die spanische oder französischen Quartern haben, irgendwo bei Spanien, Frankreich?
Die Vernichtung der Armada?
Dass dann die Briten mehr härter am Wind segeln konnten als die Spanier und in dem Fall durch ihre Konstruktion der Boote einen erheblichen Navigationsvorteil hatten.
Kann man sich gut vorstellen. Ich meine, damit kann man ja quasi um sie herumfahren und die stehen dann halt doof rum.
Genau.
Die können dann nicht hinterher, aber man kann halt wegfliegen oder...
Man weiß ja wieder, wo die Kanonen rausgucken. Man muss sie ja nur von vorne oder von hinten besuchen. Dann können sie an der Seite rausschießen, wie sie wollen.
Ja, Segeltechnik war am Anfang vor allem Wirtschafts- und Militärtechnik. Bevor es irgendwie so Spaß an der Freude wurde. Genau. Fischerei mag auch noch mal eine Rolle gespielt haben, aber ich denke mal, die nennenswerten technischen Fortschritte dürften sich in dem Bereich abgespielt haben, wie immer. Wie immer.
Wirtschaft und Militär, genau. Ich meine, der Militär wird wohl auch wirklich viel über der Technik vorangetrieben haben. Merkt man in heutigen Booten nicht so sehr. Das ist mehr der Sport dann, der dann die neue Technik bringt.
Ja, jetzt ist das ja wirklich so Formel-1-Rennen. Was gibt es da hier, dieser... America's Cup.
Das ist wohl das populärste.
Ja, aber da gibt es noch mehr, oder?
Manchmal gibt es so... Wende Globe, was ich zum Beispiel ganz interessant immer finde. Ich guck mir das gerne an, weil die Leute sich da so malträtieren.
Wie heißt das?
Wende Globe. Ja, ich bin nicht so... Ich meine, Französisch ist ja schlecht. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig ausgeführt habe, aber das ist Französisch. Ja, Wende Globe. Also die machen einmal rund um die Erde. Das geht meistens von Les Sables in der Britannien los und endet da auch. Die Boote legen da auch nicht an irgendwo mitten in der Welt, sondern die machen dann so in 100 Tagen einmal um die Welt. Und es ist auch in einem großen Boot immer nur eine Person an Bord. Sie fahren auch einhändig sozusagen. Und die malträtieren sich, dass sie da versuchen, so schnell wie möglich um die Erde zu segeln.
In 80 Tagen?
Ja, nicht 80, die machen 100 oder so. 100, ein paar zerquetschte.
100 Tage einmal rum?
Einmal rum.
Wie lange hast du für deine Überfahrung des Atlantiks gebraucht?
Also ich brauchte nur für die Atlantik 18 Tage. Aber das war ja nur von den Kanarischen Inseln bis nach Barbados. Und die segeln ja von Les Sables los, machen einmal die Runde unten im Südpolarmeer. Und dann sind sie da unten an den Südcups von Afrika, irgendwo bei Neuseeland, unten im Südcup und machen die einmal so eine Runde. Und dann kommen die dann oben wieder bei Südamerika herum und fahren dann wieder durch den Atlantik hoch, an Brasilien lang hoch, irgendwie nach Les Sables in die Britannien.
Erstmal, dass ich jetzt hier für eine Sendung Google Earth irgendwie als Begleitdokumentationsprogramm öffne, um sich das hier mal so klar zu machen. Ja, das sind ja nur so ein paar Grad irgendwie. Also von, was hattest du, von den Kanarischen Inseln? Bist du wohin?
Kanarische Inseln, dort, was du jetzt auf dem Bild hast, bis rüber nach Barbados. Das ist die östlichste der karibischen Inseln.
Also 15 Grad und dann Barbados. Die östlichste?
Die östlichste der Inseln, die am weitesten rausguckt.
Ist das hier Bridgetown oder was?
Genau, das ist Barbados. Das ist die östlichste. Bis dorthin.
Also bis knapp 60 Grad.
Das sind so circa 2600 Meilen.
Ja, ich wollte es vorhin jetzt gerade mal in Grad haben. Also es sind 45 Grad sozusagen von den 360.
45 mal 60.
Bitte?
45 mal 60 dann.
45 mal 60?
Ja, wir reden immer von Seemeilen.
Nee, ich wollte jetzt den Vergleich haben zu einmal um die ganze Welt. Da hat man ja 360 Grad, du hast 18 Tage gebraucht, um 45 Grad abzufahren. Und die wollen halt in 100 Tagen, also sozusagen in 5-fachen, wollen sie dann irgendwie das 6-, 7-fache, 8-fache umfahren.
Ja, die sind dann halt sehr sportlich.
Ja, ganz gut unterwegs. Und die müssen leiden, ja?
Die müssen leiden, ja, ja. Das finde ich als masochistisch.
Wie machen die denn das, wenn die da alleine fahren? Ich meine, alleine um die Welt? Schlafen die da überhaupt?
Ja.
Aber mit Autopilot? Autopilot ist verboten oder was?
Aber nicht durchgehend. Die haben Autopilot, aber die schlafen halt nicht lange, ne? Du schläfst maximal so, weiß nicht, wie machen die das so? 10 Minuten und dann bist du wieder wach und dann 10 Minuten. Die haben nie länger als irgendwie so eine Viertelstunde oder so, die sie schlafen in einem Stück.
Ernsthaft?
Ja.
So eine Powernap-Technik.
Irgendwie sowas. Ich sage ja erst mal, Sochismus.
Das ist ja unglaublich. Ich könnte das gar nicht. Aber keine Ahnung, ich bin auch nicht auf den Weltmeeren unterwegs. Vielleicht lernt man das ja dann automatisch.
Ich habe damals ein Interview gelesen mit so einer Weltumseglerin, die das mal gemacht hat für eine längere Zeit, um zu segeln. Die sagte, die braucht man hinterher dann fast monatelang, um wieder einen normalen Schlafrhythmus zu bekommen, um mal wieder sechs Stunden durchzuschlafen, also ein Land.
Verstehe. Das heißt, man muss sich das wirklich total angewöhnen, wenn man unterwegs ist, dass man einfach immer nur so in 15 Minuten Häppchen schläft.
Ja, wenn du allein unterwegs bist. Das ist halt der Masochismus. Krass. Ist krass.
Nur, damit man nicht in irgendeinen Tanker reinfährt.
Ja. Oder was viel schlimmer ist, also was immer so ein Horror-Szenario für mich ist, ist nicht der Tanker oder der große Frachter, den man ja sieht. Nee, wenn die irgendwas verlieren. Zum Beispiel einen Container, der ins Wasser gefallen ist, weil der irgendwie lose war und der dann so wirklich nur so ein paar Zentimeter aus dem Wasser rausguckt, den man kaum sieht, der dann vielleicht so halb schwimmt. Und dann fährt man mit seinem Joghurtbecher auf eine Metallkante.
Aua.
Ja, das wäre sehr unangenehm.
Hast du sowas schon mal gesehen?
Nein, das habe ich gehört. Also es gibt Leute, denen das passiert ist. Also das ist einschlägig in der Segler-Meinheit bekannt, dass sowas passieren kann. Bei jedem Sturm fallen mal ein paar Container runter. Es gibt es immer wieder, dass Container auch an Land angespült werden. In der Biscaya passiert das recht häufig sogar. In England auch mal. Ich habe das mal gehört, das ist schon mal in meiner Schulzeit. Das war noch in meiner Schulzeit, glaube ich, war jemand in Wangerooge. Dann hatten die dann plötzlich alle Yamaha-Motorräder. So in dem Bereich so um die hunderten Pazakwetsche Kubik. Da war ein ganzer Container von Yamaha an Land gespült worden. Und die ganze Insulaner hatten alle neue Motorräder.
Sehr praktisch. Oh Gott, das ist ja schon fast das equalinste Weltraumschrott. Ich meine, das Meer ist ja auch ganz gut versaut schon. Aber dass man natürlich dann in diesen unendlichen Meeresweiten dann auch tatsächlich darauf stößt, ergibt ja bestimmt auch eine ganze Menge Siemensgarn, oder? Gibt es auch so Loch-Nest-Drachen-Sichter?
Unglaublich viel. Unglaublich viel. Aber ich kann es auch verstehen, wie sowas passiert. Also ich hatte mal so ein Erlebnis, wo man weiß, wie solche Mythen entstehen. Das war in der Nacht. Wunderschönes Segeln nachts, ziemlich ruhig. Es war wenig Wind. Man hatte alle segelt draußen. Nichts verkleinert, weil der Wind zu stark wäre. Das Wasser war ziemlich ruhig. Es war nicht viel Welle. Man konnte sehr gut sehen, was auch im Wasser ist. Und man hat gesehen, das war eine Biolumineszenz im Wasser. Irgendwelche Algen. Und der Weg, das Boot durch das Wasser, wurde richtig so erleuchtet. Weil dort, wo das Boot langgefahren ist, war Biolumineszenz im Wasser. Man konnte richtig die Linie sehen, wo das Boot langgefahren ist. Und das sieht da so sehr toll aus. Und plötzlich siehst du in dieser Biolumineszenz kleine Geister. Kleine, sich schnell bewegende, größere bioluminisierenden Flächen, die sich so schön bewegen. Und das hat sich hinterher herausgestellt, das waren Delfine, die sehr schnell geschwommen sind und an nahe des Boots gekommen sind. In der Dunkelheit konntest du nicht sehen, dass es sich um Delfine handelt. Du hast nur dieses Biolumineszenz gesehen und es waren aus wie kleine Geister im Wasser.
Light-Tracking mit Delfinen und so.
Genau. Das ist eine Sache, die man nicht so häufig sieht. Und dann kann man sich vorstellen, das ist also echt spektakulär. Das ist echt spektakulär. Und dann kann man sich vorstellen, wie Mythen und Legenden entstehen.
Ja, wow. Na, ein bisschen Wissenschaftsgrundbildung hilft sozusagen.
Ja, genau.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass da ein paar alte Seemanns-Haudegen dann im Hafen dann aber auch mal einen zum Besten geben, was sie nicht alles so gesehen haben, etc. Genau. Also jetzt haben wir sozusagen, wir haben dieses Boot so in seinen Dimensionen so ein bisschen erfasst. Wir wissen, wie es irgendwie vorankommt. Jetzt ist das Ganze ja dann doch eine erhebliche logistische Sache, weil ich meine, wenn man dann, ich meine, acht, zehn Tage lang ohne Supermarkt... Da gehört ja schon einiges dazu. Du hast schon gesagt, du lädst dann mehrere Einkaufswagen-Zeug ab. Aber was hast du denn sozusagen noch alles an Bord, um sozusagen für alle Fälle gerüstet zu sein? Also ich meine, allein diese ganzen Geräte und so weiter, das braucht ja auch alles Strom, ne?
Ja, also das ist Unmengen an Ersatzteilen, diverser Art. Die so rumfliegen. Werkzeuge, um die wesentlichen Sachen in Größe zu sein. Die Vorräte in größeren Mengen. Wasser, Diesel.
Aber Vorräte sind alles so Dosen-Nahrung oder trocken?
Nein, nein, nein. Man kauft ganz normal aus. Man hat auch Gemüse an Bord und dergleichen. Natürlich, wenn man so längere Zeit unterwegs ist, dann wird es ein bisschen mehr dosig im Speisenplan am Ende. Am Anfang ist das Gemüse noch gut und so weiter und da.
Was gibt es heute? Linsensuppe. Und morgen auch Linsensuppe.
Nicht ganz, aber man kann Sachen aus dem Gefrierschrank. Wir haben einen Kühlschrank, der als Gefrierfach konfigurierbar ist, wenn man längere Zeit unterwegs ist. Dann kann man das auch als Gefrier-Ding mit minus 17 Grad konfigurieren. Dann kann man was Gefrorenes rausziehen. Das hält dann auch ein bisschen länger. Das ist gerade interessant, wenn man mal einen Steak haben will oder ein Stückchen Hühnchenbrust, wie man zu einem China-Gericht verarbeiten will. Das ist dann ganz schön, wenn man da ein bisschen was Fleisch rausholen kann. Da kann man ein bisschen gefrorenes Gemüse mit drin haben.
Frisst das nicht extrem viel Strom?
Das ist das Problem. Von den Technik her, Kühlschränke sind die Stromfresser an Bord. Also bei uns auch. Wir benutzen dazu zwei Kühlaggregate, die mit 12 Volt Technik betrieben werden. Also unser Boot ist alles mit 12 Volt. Alles? Alles 12 Volt im Wesentlichen. Das ist deswegen, weil 12 Volt ist die bewährte Autotechnik, die man bei jedem Autofritzen um die Ecke bekommt. Es gibt auch moderne Superjachten, die mit anderen Spannungen betrieben werden, um die Kabelbäume kleiner zu halten und die ganzen Kram. Aber das ist dann eher Exotentechnik, die teuer ist. Und unser eins will ja, was sich auch mit 12 Volt Technik ganz normal im nächsten Autohandel, wo die Massen umgesetzt werden, bedienen. Und dann möchte man eben Teile und Kabel und alles haben, was also massengefertigt und billig ist. Deswegen verwendet man dieselbe Taktik wie in Lastwagen oder Autos. Das ist einfach die Massenfertigung. Deswegen ist bei uns alles 12 Volt. Das bedeutet, man hat große Batterien an Bord. In unserem Fall ist es eine ganz normale Starterbatterie, getrennt für den Hauptdieselmotor. Und dann hat man große Hausbatterien, die die ganzen Luxussachen wie Kühlschrank, Beleuchtung und so etwas betreiben. Das ist eigentlich genauso wie im Wohnwagen, wo du meistens eine Starterbatterie hast, getrennt von der Hausbatterie. Und bei uns sind das viele Hausbatterien. Und genau gesagt sind das bei uns vier große Trojan Golfkart-Batterien, die man in diesen Golfkarren verwenden würde. Die haben den Vorteil, dass man sie tief entladen kann. Viele von den normalen Batterien, die man in Autos oder Lastwagen verwendet, sind eher nicht so empfindlich, wenn man sie ein bisschen zu tief entlädt. Wie man ja weiß, beim Segeln und beim täglichen Leben an Bord kann es schon mal sein, dass man die Batterien ein bisschen mehr entlädt, als gut ist für die Batterien. Und dann sind diese Golfkart-Batterien noch am widerstandsfähigsten, um diese Sachen zu verzeihen.
Ist das eine andere Technologie oder sind die einfach nur so?
Ja, da gibt es noch verschiedene Batterietechniken. Also ich rede jetzt von normalen Bleibatterien, wo man richtig Wasser nachfüllen kann und so weiter. Da gibt es dann noch diese zugemachten Gelbatterien und mehrere andere Batterietypen, die zum Teil bessere Eigenschaften haben, dass man die geschlossen gekapselt sind, dass man die zum Beispiel auch mehr kippen kann, dass nichts ausläuft und so. Aber ich selber persönlich ziehe immer noch die guten alten Bleibatterien vor, weil da kann ich wenigstens reingucken und kann mit dem Säureheber gucken, ob die Batterien noch in Ordnung sind. Ich kann auch ein bisschen distillertes Wasser nachkippen. Das ist also, finde ich, von der Maintenance her für mich persönlich die bessere Wahl, obwohl sie vielleicht mit der Technik schon ein bisschen altbacken sind.
Robuster einfach.
Robuster einfach. Und wir malträtieren die Batterien. Wir malträtieren sie wirklich.
Also ihr verbraucht viel Strom und häufig sind sie mal leer.
Ja, also nicht leer, aber sie werden doch tiefer entladen, als man es sich eigentlich vorstellt. Man sagt, es gibt so eine alte Regel, man sollte sie nie mehr als 50 Prozent entladen. Und wenn man sie wieder auflädt, alles, was über 80 Prozent wieder aufladen, ist an sich eigentlich vergebene Liebesmüh, wenn man nicht irgendwie mit Solarpanels oder Windgeneratoren sie weiter auflädt, oder wenn man sowieso an Landstrom angeschlossen ist. Weil also alles, was über 80 Prozent ist, dann ist die Ladekurve so flach, dass die Batterien so wenig Energie aufnehmen für so viel, was man reinstecken muss, dass es sich nicht mehr lohnt.
Ach so, dass man einfach viel Strom verbraucht, ohne dass viel hängen bleibt. Das geht gar nicht um die Zeit, sondern um, was an Energie überhaupt noch übertragen wird.
Genau, das ist diese Ladekurve. Die wird am Anfang, wenn sie schnell geladen, dann wird das Vollladen immer langsamer. Und deswegen, man sagt so Pi mal Daumen als Baum, als Daumenregel, 50 Prozent unter nicht. Und mehr als 80 macht keinen Sinn, außer man fährt sowieso gerade mit dem Motor. Oder es ergibt sich einfach, dass man es laden kann, ohne so große Kosten.
Verstehe. Vier dicke Teile, ja?
Es sind vier dicke. Und die zwei Batterien, die dann in parallel und in Reihe gemacht, gibt so circa 480 Amperestunden.
Das heißt, ihr habt sozusagen so ein Konglomerat an Akkus, die sozusagen eine Hauptstromquelle für die ganzen Hausverbraucher, unabhängig jetzt von der Motorgeschichte, weil die haltet ihr separat, weil Motor starten ist schwerer.
Wird immer funktionieren.
Ja, verschrecklich. Aber zur Not könntet ihr auch die Heimstrom dann sozusagen verwenden, weil das ja alles dasselbe System ist. Verstehe. Wann braucht man denn diesen Motor überhaupt?
Für Hafenmanöver. Im Wesentlichen, wenn du rein und rausfährst in Hafen zum Beispiel oder in eine enge Bucht, wenn du sehr manövrieren willst. Das Boot ist ja mit 40 Fuß und 12 Tonnen Gewicht schon relativ schwer und relativ unbeweglich. Man kann das auch unter Segeln bis fast zum Ankerplatz bewegen. Aber es gibt immer wieder Situationen, wo es sehr eng ist. Wo Navigation sozusagen auf den Meter genau gemacht werden muss. Und dann ist das mit Segeln unpraktisch und schwierig. Manche Mariners oder die meisten Mariners, wenn da z.B. eine richtige Marine reinfährt, also ein Sportboothafen, wo so Holzstege sind, wo man sich festmachen kann, die verbieten, dass man da unter Segeln reinfährt. Die fürchten einfach um ihre Holzstege.
Weil schlecht getroffen wird.
Genau. Und da muss man unter Motor reinfahren. Dafür wird das verwendet, wenn es mal eine kleine Tour ist und man hat dann z.B. keine andere Möglichkeit. Der Wind pustet nicht mein Wille bei anderen Wegen. Dann fährt man auch unter Motor mal eine Strecke. Oder was immer wieder mal passiert, Kanalfahrten oder Flussmündungsfahrten, wo das denn nicht geht, wo man nicht segeln kann und wo man dann Motor braucht.
Verstehe. Und kann man den Motor auch als Stromerzeuger nutzen?
Ja, weil die Lichtmaschine läuft ja. ZB in meinem Boot ist ein 55 PS Volvo Penta-Motor eingebaut. Ein sehr klassischer alter Dieselmotor. Das Design ist bestimmt 25 oder 30 Jahre alt oder älter. Also ganz klassisch, nicht so common real wie ein modernes Dieselauto, sondern ein richtig altes, klassisches. Also der läuft noch weiter, wenn man den Strom abzieht.
Auch hier wieder Zuverlässigkeit. Genau, genau.
Der wird auch noch abgeschaltet, indem man also eben da den Diesel wegnimmt.
Diesel dann aus.
Ja, genau. Und das hat natürlich eine Lichtmaschine. Und die Lichtmaschine wird dann verwendet, auch um den zu laden. Das bedeutet, wenn man dann mit dem Segeln fertig ist und dann zum Beispiel nicht in eine Marina fährt, sondern in eine Bucht fährt, um zu ankern, hat man durch den Motor, der dann im Moment läuft, noch mal Strom, der die Batterien auflädt, je nachdem, wie lang die Anfahrt dann ist, wo man das dann machen muss, wie weit man sich da reinschlängeln muss. Und man hat auch heiß Wasser. Weil das Kühlwasser vom Motor wird verwendet, um im Heißwasserbereiter einen Tank, bei mir von 40 Litern, von Wasser zu erhitzen, mit der Motorkühlung, sodass heiß Wasser da ist, zum Abspülen, zum Duschen und so weiter.
Das heißt, den wirft man auch immer mal wieder an, wenn man jetzt 18 Tage unterwegs ist, und man will mal irgendwie heiß duschen?
Nee, das ist verschieden, wie man das machen will. Es gibt Leute, die machen das auf die Art und Weise. Ich selber fand es nicht so gut, die große Hauptmaschine nur zum Stromerzeugen anzuwerfen, weil die braucht natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Diesel, nur weil sie läuft. Und die Lichtmaschine ist eigentlich nicht ihr Hauptding, was sie drehen soll. Sie soll eigentlich die Schraube drehen. Und das ist eigentlich ein Nebeneffekt, dass sie auch Strom erzeugen kann über die Lichtmaschine. Ist nicht so mein Ding. Ich denke, man kann effizienter Strom erzeugen, wenn man das hat. Und ich habe deswegen noch einen getrennten Dieselgenerator, eine zweite kleine Maschine. Und dieser Dieselgenerator ist ein Wechselstromgenerator, der erzeugt richtig so, was bei uns so Strom aus der Steckdose bedeutet.
Also 220 Volt.
240 Volt. Und der betreibt dann das Ladegerät vom Boot so, als würde eine Landstromsteckdose drin sein. Und der lädt dann die Batterien. Man kann alles in die Steckdosen stecken. Man kann zum Beispiel, um Gas zu sparen, sich dann zum Beispiel ein Wasser-Elektrikettel, also ein Wasserkocher, kann man sich dann Tee und Kaffee kochen und so was. Es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten, die Batterien zu laden. Also einmal, wie gesagt, die Hauptmaschine. Dann, viele Segler haben natürliche Energiequellen. Wie zum Beispiel, wir haben auch noch einen Windgenerator. Also hinten so ein Windrad, was sich dreht, was sehr gut ist, was ich sehr gut finde. Was sozusagen immer mitläuft.
Das ist oben am Mast dran oder was?
Nein, das ist hinten noch mal ein getrennter kleiner Mast. Hinten am Heck des Boots, der so hochgeht, dass die Flügel gerade so hoch sind, dass man sie nicht mit der Hand erreichen kann.
Also so auf drei, vier Metern oder so?
Und das Ding läuft hinten mit. Und das liefert eigentlich so eine Grundlast von Strom. Die ständig in das 12-Volten-Netz reingehen, wenn man zum Beispiel segelt. Und die vielleicht helfen, Autopiloten zu füttern und die Kühlschränke zu füttern. Je nachdem, wie stark der Wind ist, schafft er eben einen Teil davon. Eigentlich fast nie alles. Man muss immer noch ein Stückchen nachladen.
Also es versorgt nicht jetzt wirklich den Bedarf, aber es lädt einfach permanent immer wieder auf.
Aber es wird meistens bei mir mehr entnommen aus den Batterien, als es reinkommt.
Auch in so Ruhephasen, wenn man schläft, weil einfach kühlschränke läuft immer wieder an.
Man hat dann schlechten Radio an, man lädt mal seinen iPod auf und die Kühlschränke sind halt die größten Stromfresser bei uns.
Ja, okay, aber es reduziert sozusagen den Stromverbrauch. Könnte man da nicht einfach gleich mehrere von diesen Dingern dann?
Ja, das ist dann auch eine Platzfrage, wie groß ist denn der? Kann ich jetzt gar nicht auswendig sagen, aber ich könnte maximal zwei davon hinten, ich könnte mir noch einen zweiten Mast hinten auf rechts und links einen hin machen. Und dann hätte ich dann am Heck zwei dieser Windgeneratoren. Würde ich nicht machen wollen, also was momentan noch fehlt, was bei meinem Boot noch nicht da ist, was ich immer schon mal machen wollte, was aber momentan optische Gründe habe, das ich nicht habe, ist Solarpanels. Ich würde ganz gerne noch ganz klar Solarpanels haben. Wenn Sonneneinstellung ist, dass mir dann also die Batterien geladen werden von Solarpanels. Und da habe ich das Problem, dass Solarpanels natürlich eine große Fläche brauchen.
Also auch direkt für Stromerzeugung?
Direkt für Stromerzeugung, also die ganz normalen Halbleiter Solarpanels.
Also Photovoltaik.
Photovoltaik, genau. Das ist an sich sehr beliebt bei Seglern. Es ist aber immer die Problematik mit dem Platz, die das hier braucht. Und dann ist also bei typischen Segelbooten dann häufig die Taktik, dass man hinten einen Bogen baut am Heck, wo dann oben drauf zum Beispiel drei, vier Solarpaneels drauf montiert werden, die dann sozusagen aber die Sicht so beschränken und das Ganze dann so verbaut und kompakt aus. Ich konnte mich noch nicht durchringen. Die Ästhetik hat mich bisher noch nicht so angesprochen.
Wie viel Fläche müsste man da schon jetzt so verwenden, damit das irgendwie sinnvoll ist?
Da müsste ich jetzt genau nachgucken, aber im Wesentlichen ist es, glaube ich, also wenn mir das Sinn macht, müssen drei oder vier von den 120 Watt-Paneelen hin. Da müsste man jetzt mal nachgucken, was die typischen Kyocera-120-Watt-Panele, wie groß die sind. Also Kyocera ist einer von den großen Herstellern, die also so Solarpanels herstellen. Und dann guckt man sich an, wie groß das ist, doch ich bin mit 120 Watt, die sind also recht groß. Das sind relativ, weiß ich so, einen...
120 Watt. Was heißt das? Maximale...
Maximal unter den besten Bedingungen, dass sie liefern.
Also wenn man so irgendwie am Equator bei Vollpower irgendwie rumeidelt.
Dann hat der 120 Watt so mittags um 12.
Davon dann drei Stück.
Vier wäre gut.
Vier Stück. Na, da kriegt man ja dann den Kühlschrank auch locker mit gefahren.
Ja, da kann man auch die Batterie mit aufladen. Wenn du dann einen sonnigen Tag hast, dann kannst du dein Funkgerät, dein Laptop und mit dem Inverter, also der, der aus 12 Volt wieder 22 Volt macht und alles, den ganzen Kram von den Solarpanels füttern.
Größenordnung?
Weiß ich nicht auswendig.
Vier Stelle.
Ich glaube, so im Bereich 500, 600 Dollar. Für eins?
Okay, gut, sehr weniger, als ich dachte.
Aber das Problem ist bei mir noch gewesen, dass ich mich wirklich zu einem Stahlgerüst verpflichte, dass ich da hinten auf dem Boot raufbaue, was mir die Sicht wegnimmt.
Kann man das nicht irgendwie oben auf dem Mast draufknallen?
Wegen der Segel und wegen der Leinen, die da langfahren oben am Mast, geht das nicht.
Das ist keine gute Idee.
Nein.
Auch so mit der Aerodynamik, wegen etc.
Nein, nein, das funktioniert nicht.
Vielleicht müsste man so den, was weiß ich, gibt es hier nicht auch in gebogen, dass man so den Mast damit auskleiden kann?
Die müssen hier nach oben in die Sonne zeigen. Die muss man sogar möglichst noch verstellbar anbringen, dass du sie doch mehrfach am Takt verstellen kannst, wie die Sonne jeweils steint. Also das ist ja auch die Sache. Man könnte sie sich auch an die Rilling schrauben, also an den See zauen und hochklappen. Das Problem ist, wenn man unterwegs ist, dann hat man ja vielleicht irgendwie von den Wellen her die Befürchtung, die ballern da dagegen. Das ist auch nicht das Schönste. Deswegen ist der sicherste Platz immer noch ein Bogen hinten am Heck, wo man die oben drauf wie ein Dach montiert. Das ist glaube ich der beste Weg. Konnte ich mich bisher nicht so durchringen.
Okay, aber es könnte sozusagen kommen. Und wenn man ein Boot hat, was das jetzt vor seiner Bauweise her eh schon mitbringt, dann ist das eine absolut sinnvolle... Ich meine, da kann man ja im Prinzip, wenn man es jetzt darauf anlegt, bei solchen... Gut, ich meine, man hat jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer bessere Bedingungen. Aber wenn man jetzt wie du da so in karibischen Breiten rumdonnert und so, dann könnten da ja so eine Batterie von diesen Panelen schon amtlich Energie liefern, sodass man da recht autark durch die Gegend düsen kann.
Ja, und dafür keinen Diesel verbrennen, ne?
Ja, genau.
Weil ich jetzt zum Beispiel zum Nachladen, um also diese Diskrepanz von dem, was ich rausnehme, was ich durch Windenergie bekomme, immer wieder mit einem Diesel-Generator nachliefern muss. Das ist ja nicht bei mir die Hauptmaschine, sondern ein kleinerer Diesel-Generator. Und der nimmt dann nur, zum Beispiel, der vergleicht mal, meine Hauptmaschine ist ungefähr bei drei, dreieinhalb Litern pro Stunde, was die frisst. Der Diesel-Generator macht ungefähr einen halben Liter. Und das ist ein 3,8 Kilowatt-Generator. Wechselstrom und die Lichtmaschine an der Hauptmaschine ist 60 Ampere bei 12 Volt. Mal nachrechnen, das ist viel weniger. Das sind ja nur 700 Watt. Wie viel ist das? Knapp 800 Watt oder sowas?
Ich habe jetzt nicht mehr so richtig mitrechnen können.
Also 12 Volt mal circa 60 Ampere. 12 mal 60 sind 720 Watt. Und der Diesel-Generator macht 3,8 Kilowatt. Sustain so ziemlich. Fast 4 Mal Überlast. Und das macht der mit einem halben Liter.
Verstehe. Das ist schon deutlich effizienter.
Deutlich effizienter. Wär's wirklich nur gedacht für Show-Maschinen.
Aber der Sprit geht halt weg, wenn man den Sprit dann irgendwann mal braucht. Kann ja auch sein. Ich weiß nicht, so Flaute.
Ja, dann muss man vielleicht mal, wenn man nicht geduldig genug ist, muss man dann die Hauptmaschine mal anwerfen.
Kommt das überhaupt vor, so in diesen Kreisen? So Wind, erst in überhaupt kein Windstil? Nichts geht mehr?
Das hatten wir letztens erst. Das kann passieren. Also in der Karibik ist ja dieser Bereich der sogenannten Passatwinde. Die sind relativ konstanter. Immer Wind aus Osten. Durch Erddrehung und durch die Wettersysteme hast du ja einen Gürtel um die Erde, jeweils nördlich und südlich des Äquators, wo Wind relativ konstant ist. Im englischen Sprachraum wird das ja Tretwindzone benannt, weil dort die Handelsschifffahrt immer lang gefahren ist. Und da kannst du ohne Probleme in dem Bereich immer mit einem konstanten Wind aus nördlich des Äquators, nördlässigen Richtung und südlich des Äquators, südöstlichen Richtung rechnen. Je nach Jahreszeit immer stabiler, immer nicht so stabiler. Aber das ist auch der Gebiet, wo man sich bei einer Atlantiküberquerung hinein will, um dort konstante Winde zu bekommen, immer gut vorwärts zu kommen.
Also mit anderen Worten, Flaute ist selten, aber kann passieren.
Ja, kann passieren, wenn zum Beispiel schlechtes Wetter kommt. Hatten wir es letztens in der Karibik, dann fuhr da so ein Gebiet von Schlechtwetter durch die Gegend nördlich von uns, das sich hinterher zu einem Hurricane ausgebildet hat. Und das ändert natürlich schon sehr weitflächig. Um sich drum herum das Wetter und auch die Winde. Und das hat wie so einen Staubsauger den Wind so aufgesaugt, dass dann plötzlich bei uns Wind aus Süden kam, was bei der Jahreszeit eigentlich absolut unüblich ist. Aber es war eben halt, das war die Hurricane Earl, der hat dann also weit nordöstlich von uns, er war noch weit entfernt, aber das Wetter hat total beeinflusst.
Ja, Wetter. Wetter ist natürlich so der ständige Begleiter. Das ist fast das Einzige, was man da sieht. Du hast ja da so allerlei Sensorik am Start.
Ja, es gibt eine Menge an Elektronik in einem Boot. Das fängt also mit solchen Kleinigkeiten an, dass man ein Messgerät braucht, um zu wissen, wie schnell ist man durchs Wasser. Die Geschwindigkeit durchs Wasser, das ist diese Geschwindigkeit, also die Geschwindigkeit, die nicht das Boot wirklich zurücklegt, sondern durchs Wasser. Wenn man zum Beispiel Strömung hat, dann ist das ja beeinflusst von der Strömung. Die Geschwindigkeit über Grund, also über die Erdfläche, kann man mit GPS ermitteln. Das ist ja auch erst seit neuerer Zeit, dass man das kann. Und wenn man dann die Geschwindigkeit über Grund mit der Geschwindigkeit im Wasser vergleicht, dann kann man zum Beispiel sehen, ob man irgendwelche Strömungen, die man angetrieben oder gebremst vom Wasser, von Strömungen.
Die Differenz ergibt automatisch, wo das Wasser gerade fließt.
Genau, das kann in verschiedene Richtungen fließen. Aber das gibt zum Beispiel einen Anhaltspunkt, dass du zum Beispiel weißt, du bist gerade in einem Strömungsgebiet, du wirst mitgetragen in eine Richtung, aber du kriegst den Strom auf die Nase. Das ist dann das ganz Gruselige, wo du merkst, ich komme gar nicht mehr so schnell vor, als ich eigentlich gerne möchte.
Ist sowas Standard?
Das ist eigentlich Standard. Ja, soweit Standard, wie gut es gepflegt wird. Weil die meisten Systeme basieren gerade um die Geschwindigkeit des Wassers. Durch festzustellen auf kleine Schaufelrädchen. So ganz kleine Schaufelrädchen, vielleicht so von 2-3 cm Durchmesser. Das ist irgendwo am Rumpf befestigt, unten im Wasser. Und das dreht sich durch das verbleibschließende Wasser. Und sobald man längere Zeit irgendwo an einem Ort verbleibt, setzen sich da gerne diverse Unterwasser-Lebewesen rein. Also ich habe da schon kleine Kräpse, kleine irgendwelche Würmer. Und was ich ja immer rausgeprokelt habe, immer wenn man eine längere Zeit irgendwo voll Anker gelegen hat oder in der Marina gelegen hat und Landbesuche gemacht hat, muss man es mal freirückfrei blasen. Genau. Das ist dann immer eine ganz interessante Eigenheit, weil man muss ja diesen Sensor erstmal durch die Bootshülle nach innen bringen. Das bedeutet, man schraubt ihn raus, hat manchmal so ein großes Loch, so mehrere Zentimeter Durchmesser, wo dann Wasser reinkommt. Dann muss man schnell den Blindstopfen draufschrauben, dass kein Wasser mehr reinkommt. Dann kann man den sauber machen. Das restliche Wasser muss man erstmal rauspumpen, und was da reingekommen ist, rauspumpen und wegwischen. Dann macht man den Blindstopfen wieder auf, checkt den Sensor wieder rein und dreht ihn wieder rein. Dann kurzzeitig mal ein richtiges Loch im Boot.
Das macht man auch nur am Hafen.
Das habe ich auch unterwegs gemacht.
Ach echt?
Ja, ja.
Ach so, weil der Sensor sich wieder verkrempft hat?
Nee, der war zu gewesen. Ich habe es vergessen zu machen. Und dann ist mir der Fall aufgefallen, oh, das Boot-Speed zeigt Null an. Ich wusste aber, ich bin in Strömung in diesem Gebiet. Es wäre interessant zu wissen, wie das Boot durchs Wasser macht. Und dann bin ich auch mal gesagt, naja, dann muss man noch mal runtergehen. Und dann fahrt auch mal das Ding mal sauber machen.
Was gibt einem das so im Wesentlichen für so eine Information? Was mache ich mit der Information, wenn ich weiß, dass ich jetzt Strömung in die Richtung habe, in die Richtung?
Es gibt dir zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit, zu ermitteln, wann du vielleicht ankommen wirst. Ich nehme mal an, ganz typisch, wenn man in dem Bereich eine Karibik hat, über den Nordaquatorialen Strom, den Antillenstrom, das sind Ströme, die in bestimmte Richtung hinter den Golfstrom ergeben. Also das Nordaquatoriale Strom kommt an der Westküste Afrikas nordequatorialer Strom. Das ist ein Strom, der beginnt. Ich weiß nicht, das ist ein Rest vom Humboldt-Strom, oder was weiß ich. Also irgendein Strom, der bei Afrika nach Norden fließt. Irgendwo in den Kap-Werde-Inseln von dieser Nase Afrikas nach Westen abgeleitet wird. Genau, der fließt da an dieser afrikanischen Küste erst nach Norden. Und dann wird er umgelenkt nach Westen und fließt rüber in die Karibik. In der Karibik wird er abgelenkt nach Norden und fließt dann als Golfstrom an der nordamerikanischen Küste und fließt dann nach Europa. Das ist unsere Heizung.
Das ist das, was uns das schöne Wetter gibt, obwohl wir eigentlich so weit weg sind vom Äquator, wo es auch kalt sein könnte.
Verschiedene Teile der Erde heißt er in verschiedenen, also der beginnt als Nordequatorialer Strom von der afrikanischen Küste rüber in die Karibik und ist dort der Antillenstrom und wird dann in der nordamerikanischen Küste der Golfstrom.
Also der heißt schon Nordequatorial, wo er noch im Süden des Äquators ist?
Da heißt er wieder anders. Tut mir leid, weiß ich nicht auswendig.
Also dieser große Strom auf jeden Fall, der durch den Atlantik durchpflügt. Ja gut, aber ich meine, ich weiß noch schon von der GPS-Messung her, was so meine reale Geschwindigkeit ist, um jetzt meine Geschwindigkeit abzuschätzen, dann ist mir die Strömung noch eigentlich egal.
Mir ist es zum Beispiel nicht ganz egal, weil ich zum Beispiel damit also feststellen kann, wie gerade die Tide ist. Also zum Beispiel, wenn zum Beispiel ein sehr Küstengebiet ist, wie zum Beispiel in der nordamerikanischen Küste, die also sehr viel Tide auch hat, wie hier bei uns auch in einer englischen und in der französischen Küste, sagt dir das zum Beispiel aus, wie stark der Strom gerade ist. Und dann weißt du zum Beispiel auch gerade, wie die Tide ist, wenn gerade kein Tidenkalender in der Nähe ist. Oder es ist ganz interessant zu wissen, wie viel man vorhalten muss. Du musst ja zum Beispiel diesen Tidenstrom auch berücksichtigen, in dem Winkel, wo du hinfährst. Also du weißt zum Beispiel, der Tidenstrom setzt dir zum Beispiel in einem Winkel von 40 Grad auf die Nase sozusagen und drückt dein Boot in der Richtung.
Also die Gezeiten, die merkt man richtig.
Oh, die sind deutlich sichtbar. Es gibt Situationen, wo du einfach manche Sachen nicht befahren kannst, weil die Gezeiten verhindern würden, dass du vorwärts kommst. Es gibt in sehr gezeitenintensiven Gebieten, wie zum Beispiel Nordfrankreich oder England, die Englanküste, Gebiete oder in Schottland oben, wo du mal 6, 7, 8 Knoten Strom in der falschen Richtung haben kannst.
Verstehe, wenn man selber nicht mehr als 6, 7, 8 Knoten fährt?
Dann kommst du nicht vorwärts, dann fährst du rückwärts.
Super, das ist ungefähr so, als würde so auf der Autobahn die Fahrbahn sich unter einem in die andere Richtung bewegen.
Genau, genau.
Bis auf eine Rolltreppe laufen, in die falsche Richtung.
Das möchtest du also überwachen. Ich bin ja der Kontrollfreak. Und ich möchte ganz gerne sehen, ob meine Rechnungen mit den Tidenkalendern, ob die auch alle stimmen.
Der Sensor ist allein schon deshalb wichtig, um einfach so eine Gewissheit zu generieren, ob die Annahmen stimmen.
Genau, dass ich im Tabin Tidenkalender den richtigen Tag aufgeschlagen habe und nicht jetzt irgendwie von letzten Jahres geguckt habe oder von einem Monat vorher. Hast du den nicht eh in elektronischer Form? Auch, ja.
Aber du hast auch immer alles noch mal als Buch, falls...
Die meisten noch mal als Buch, dass man noch mal nachgucken kann. Ganz klassisch. Ja, das ist eine Sache, dass man einfach braucht.
Sie ist draufgekommen, dass man so was gebrauchen könnte. Also, wenn die Gezeiten da so an einem reißen, dann ist das natürlich klar.
Zum Beispiel eine kleine Insel in der Karibik, da hast du keine Tide, weil das ist nicht genug Landmasse, dass der Strom drumherum irgendwo was Relevantes an Ebbe und Flut erzeugen würde. Aber wenn du eine Landmasse hast wie ein Kontinent, ein nordamerikanischer Kontinent, Europa, das ist schon substanziell, was da an Tide anläuft.
Okay, das reißt richtig.
Und das ist relevant und da muss man gucken. Das hat Relevanz. Oder du musst zum Beispiel auch wissen, dass man an Ebbe und Flut hat, wenn du ankerst. Wenn du zum Beispiel dir aussuchst, du weißt zum Beispiel, dein Kiel ist zwei Meter tief und du ankerst an einer schönen Stelle und sagst zum Beispiel, das ist wunderschön hier. Ich habe gerade eine Wassertiefe von drei Metern. Ich ankere da und sage, das ist ja wunderschön. Aber dass du vielleicht zu Hochwasser geankert hast und das vielleicht nochmal zwei Meter Wasser wegfließen sollte und dann plötzlich nur noch ein Meter Wasser unter dem Kiel hättest, dann unter so einer Schräglage wäre es fast sozusagen Umfeld, das wäre unangenehm. Also man muss schon wissen, was man tut.
Nachvollziehbar. Okay, aber das ist ja sicherlich nicht dein einziger Sensor, den du jetzt machst.
Nein, das ist doch ein Windmesser. Das ist also ein Windmesser, der dir die Windgeschwindigkeit mitteilt und die Windrichtung. Dass ich also sofort auf einen Blick sehen kann, wie schnell ist der Wind und aus welcher Richtung kommt er. Gut, das kann ich auch sehen an den Segeln. Das kann ich auch sehen, wenn ich einen Finger anfeuchte und in die Luft halte. Das ist also auch sichtbar. Das ist nicht unbedingt überlebensnotwendig. Es ist schön zu sehen.
Ja, es ist auch schöner, das aufzuzeichnen und da so ewige Logs zu haben.
Das könnte man also auch machen, aber habe ich meistens nicht, weil ich aus drohenden Gründen meistens ein Laptop nicht ständig in Betrieb habe. Aber es ist ganz interessant zu sehen und man kann dann zum Beispiel auch einen Winkel schnell mal sich rechnen lassen von den Navigationsinstrumenten, wenn ich zum Beispiel einen anderen, wenn ich zum Beispiel kreuzen will gegen den Wind, immer mit diesen Winkeln von 40 bis 60 Grad gegen den Wind, um mich also sozusagen genau in die Windrichtung hinein zu bewegen, dann ist es vielleicht ganz interessant zu sehen gerade, wie wird denn der Winkel sein, damit ich jetzt also in die Richtung komme, dann kann er das mit dieses Dreieck schon gleich berechnen und sagen, da musst du noch weitere paar Grad fahren, dann schaffst du es bis zum Zielpunkt, dann auf einer Seite zu segeln. Das ist ganz interessant. Dann hat man natürlich den Tiefenmesser, ein essentielles Instrument, nicht unbedingt beim Segeln, aber beim Einfahrt in Häfen, Buchten, Ankerplätze finden.
Was, das Ultraschall?
Ja, das ist der ganz normale Sonar. Das ist also mit Ultraschall, der nach unten misst und dann sagt zum Beispiel, du hast jetzt noch 4 Meter Tiefe. Ist der immer aktiv?
Ständig. Auch im freien Atlantik? Ja, man könnte immer unter einem durchfahren.
Genau, das hat einen Erschreckenseffekt. Man hat eigentlich, da steht auf dem Endlich, weil also der misst bei mir so maximal so 140 bis 160 Meter Tiefe. Dann setzt er auf und dann zeigt er mir den letzten Wert an. Der blinkt dann allerdings, der letzte Wert, da sieht man so 140 Meter oder 100 Meter oder irgendwas und es blinkt. Du weißt, man ist dann in einem tieferen Bereich. Plötzlich sieht man 3 Meter und es blinkt. Da weiß man, dass ein Fischschwarm unter einem durch ist, kurzzeitig oder ein Delfin oder irgendein anderes.
Oder einen Container mit Yamaha-Motorrädern.
Jetzt müssen wir vorher Bescheid sagen können. Man könnte ihn vielleicht auch ausschalten, aber in meiner Bootskonfiguration mit der Vernetzung sind die alle miteinander vernetzt und es ist gar nicht so einfach, die getrennt auszuschalten. Das ist bei mir von der Firma Rehmarine ein einfaches Bussystem, wo man also sozusagen Power und einen Datenkabel hat. Power Grond und einen Kabel, drei Kabel glaube ich sind das. Wo dann alle Geräte miteinander vernetzt sind und dann auch in einem Daisy-Chain sind sozusagen, die wir nach Strom versorgen darüber. Da muss ich das ganze System abschalten, dann werden auch alle Geräte auch abgeschaltet.
Das beantwortet zumindest schon mal die nächste Frage. Also das ist sozusagen so ein Sensornetzwerk und du kannst dir alle Daten von allen Sensoren quasi über einen Kabel angucken lassen. Ist das eine Sternverkabelung?
Nein, ein Bussystem, so ein Daisy-Chain-System. Das erinnert so ein bisschen an das gute alte Apple Talk, also dieses Local Talk-Netz. Das sind so Daisy-Chain, eine Seite rein, eine Seite raus, eine Seite raus, wird zu kleinen Transsivern. Die Geschwindigkeit ist eher so eine serielle Schnittstelle. Es basiert so ein bisschen auf so eine serielle Basis. Es wird aber auch inzwischen mutant abgelöst in den ganz neueren Sachen mit mehr Ethernet-basiertem System, mit automatischer IP-Nummernvergabe und dass die Geräte Ethernet-mäßig vertreite Netz werden. Aber meine Boltinstrumente sind so 2004. Und da war das noch nicht üblich. Da hat man das noch nicht gemacht.
Das ist ja auch eine ganz andere Komplexität, die man sich da in die Backe klebt, wenn das alles erstmal Ethernet ist. Ich meine, in dem Bereich, denke ich mal, werden sie das auch erst einführen, wenn es rigide ist und gerade die Ethernet-basierten Sensornetzwerke. Es ist definitiv was kommt. Ich hatte übrigens auch schon mal ein tolles Chaosradio Express. Ich placke ja mal ganz gerne in meiner eigenen Sendung. Das zeigt, dass die Dinge immer doch sehr schön zusammenhängen. Und zwar, was war denn das noch gleich? Ah ja, hier, CRE116, mobile ad hoc Netzwerke. Da kommt das gar nicht so zur Sprache in dem Titel, aber unter anderem waren halt auch diese Sensornetzwerke ein Thema. Ja, was hast du noch für, das war das bestimmt noch nicht alles, Strömung, Wind, Tiefenmesser?
Der eine macht noch Wassertemperatur. Man sehen kann, wie das Wasser so ist. Das ist mehr so dieser Großzähnersatz, vom Schwimmen, wie warm ist das Wasser. Das sind im Wesentlichen die Sensoren, die wirklich Sachen physikalisch ums Boot aufnehmen.
Und so Wetterkram?
Das komme ich noch gleich zu. Das ist im Wesentlichen, dass du nochmal an Bord einen Barometer hast, dass du starke Druckabfälle sehen kannst. Also schlechte Wetter-Ankündigungen. Die Ankündigung des schlechten Wetters ist hier immer, dass die starke Fallen des Barometers über eine bestimmte Zeit weg sind. Guck, die letzten drei Stunden hat so und so viel Hektopascal gesunken. Und dann ist so, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, da kommt das. Das Druckgefüge ist schon so, dass der Wind wird stärker. Da könnte für schlechtes Wetter kommen.
Erfahrende sehen man ja das wahrscheinlich schon durch so einen geschärften Blick in die Ferne schon längst weiß.
Man kann zum Beispiel an Wolken erkennen, dass sich zum Beispiel an bestimmten Wolkenkonfigurationen, wie sich das Wetter entwickelt. Ob man zum Beispiel in der Nähe einer Kaltfront ist oder hinten in der Warmpfront. Und dass man sehen kann, wie das Wetter sich entwickelt, wie es ausschauen müsste. Das Wetterkurs, den man belegen kann für Segler, da lernt man das wie die Wolken zu gucken. Auch diesen Karlsruher Wolkenatlas.
Aber wir sind ja Geeks, wir machen das ja alles mit Technik, oder?
Ja, das ist im Wesentlichen Kommunikation. Und zwar, die Sensorik ist sehr weit ausgepriemt. Die Wetterdienste weltweit haben überall Sensoren. Das heißt, jeglicherlei kommerzielle Schiffe, Flugzeuge, Bullen im Ozean, Wetterstationen an Flughäfen liefern hier ein weltweites sensorisches Netzwerk. Das ist hier unglaublich groß. Wetterdaten ständig in Realtime an die Wetterdienste. Diese auch miteinander austauschen, diese Daten. Überall ständig. Und das geht da ein in diverse Rechenmodelle. Viele Wetterdienste haben eigene Rechenmodelle. Die tauschen auch die Wetterdaten. Und die rechnen dann für bestimmte Gebiete simulationsmäßig das Wetter aus, wie das so sein wird. Und was man jetzt machen muss, als Segler ist, sich genügend Kommunikationsinfrastruktur an Bord zu stellen, um jetzt von den Leuten Wettervorhersagen zu bekommen. Und das mache ich kommunikativ, indem ich halt über verschiedene Quellen die aktuellen Wettervorhersagen bekommen kann. Und das hängt natürlich stark davon ab, wo man gerade ist. Wenn du in der Landennähe bist, gibt es die ganz normalen landengestützten Kommunikationsmittel. Also man kann per Wi-Fi, wenn man zum Beispiel im Hafen ist, vielleicht ein Wi-Fi-Signal aufnehmen. Oder man hat ein Telefon, mit dem man sowas sich angucken kann. Oder man hat Radio oder Fernsehen, was man guckt. Oder man geht zum Hafenmeistern, guckt das angeschlagene Wettervorhersagen, der ausgehängt hat, an. Sowas kann man machen. Oder wenn man offshore ist, muss man natürlich die Kommunikation haben. Wie bei mir ist, man holt sich den Wettervorkast ab, zum Beispiel über Kurzwelle. Da gibt es die Möglichkeit, Kurzwellen-Fax. Da werden ganz klassisch regelmäßig von vielen Wetterdiensten Wetterkarten, Isobankarten, Vorhersagekarten, Analysekarten ständig ausgestrahlt als Fax.
Aber nicht Fax im Sinne von G3-Fax, sondern so ein eigener Fax-Simile-Standard für Kurzwelle, der jetzt nicht bidirektional ist, sondern die senden einfach permanent diese Bilder.
Genau, im Broadcast-Verfahren, man empfängt das. Die haben also einen festen Zeitplan. Man weiß, um so und so viel Uhr kommt diese Information als Fax raus. Man stellt seinen Kurzwellenempfänger ein, verbindet ihn mit dem Computer. Es gibt verschiedene Methoden. Die einfachste Methode ist einfach ein Audiokabel vom Ausgang an die Soundkarte vom Computer. Da gibt es Programme, die dann also dieses Signal lesen und daraus dann Fax machen auf dem Bildschirm. Und jetzt möchte ich dir die Wetterkarte anzeigen.
Und das ist eine einfache Digitalisierung, die da sozusagen stattfindet? So wie früher im Osten, als sie da irgendwie die Computerprogramme über den Fernseher ausgestrahlt haben.
So was in der Ecke, ja. Aber es ist halt, das ist interessant, es gibt sogar Wetter, es gibt sogar Grauwertfaxe, zum Beispiel die NOAA. Strahlt also... North American Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration. Das ist das amerikanische Wetterdienst. Die machen auch dieses Hurricane Center in Miami, die also die Vorhersagen machen für die ganze Karibik. Und die machen ein weltweites Wettermodell. Und die haben mehrere Stationen, die noch ganz klassisch Faxe ausstrahlen. Der Deutsche Wetterdienst macht auch Wetterfaxe. Die machen sowas auch. Vier Firmen im europäischen Bereich. Und die Franz Meteo macht das auch. Also es gibt also verschiedene Gebiete, wo man segelt.
Und du hast da so ein richtiges Thermodrucker-Fax für Kurzwelle? Gar nicht.
Das mache ich ganz klassisch mit meinem... Ich habe also ein richtiges Kurzwellenfunkgerät. Also bidirektional. Nicht nur ein Weltempfänger, sondern ein richtiges bidirektionales Kurzwellenfunkgerät. Ein so genanntes Paktor-Modem, das da vorhängt. Und das ist ein deutsches Fabrikat. Ist eigentlich weltweit führend für Kurzwellenmodems. Und...
Packet Teleprinting over Radio.
Und kommt von den Amateurfunkern. Und das geht dann zum Computer. Bei mir über eine Bluetooth-Verbindung. Und... Damit steuere ich mein Kurzwellenfunkgerät und kann E-Mail oder auch solche Faxe empfangen. Ich kann also E-Mail denden und empfangen. Und kann auch... Faxe empfangen, wenn die rausgestrahlt werden. Ich kann mir aber auch Wettervorhersagen über E-Mail holen. Nämlich zum Beispiel Anfrage. Da gibt es also diverse gute alte E-Mail-basierende Server, die also mit E-Mail hin und E-Mail zurück dir Daten schicken, wenn du sie anfragst.
Das heißt, E-Mail ist sozusagen ein Dienst auf Paktor?
Genau. Es ist nur E-Mail.
Es ist kein IP oder so?
Das kann man sich eh vergleichen mit UoCP damals.
Okay, also Bilder und E-Mail sozusagen. Das ist das, was man will.
Ja, Bilder in dem Fall von Faxen ist aber getrennt, nicht über diesen Service. Also die beschränken die Attachment-Größe, weil Kurzwelle ja sehr, sehr langsam ist, sehr stark. Was dort versendet werden, sind sogenannte Gripfiles gerne als Datenfiles für Wetterbeschreibungen über eine Zeit hinweg. Dass du z.B. sagst, ich interessiere mich für eine Fläche auf der Erde von Grad so und so bis Grad so und so in Koordinaten. Für drei Tage im Voraus möchte ich z.B. gerne sehen, Wind, Wellen, Luftdruck und diesergleichen. Diese Gridded-Binary-Files enthalten eine Art rechteckbasierendes, mehrere Ebenen-Datenformat, wo dann drinne steht, die Windrichtung, die Windstärke, die Wellenrichtung, die Wellenhöhe, die Lufttemperatur, die Wassertemperatur und solche Sachen können da drinne stehen. Und die kann ich mir persönlich per E-Mail zuschicken lassen und dann grafisch auf dem Bildschirm darstellen. Mit Ist-Situationen, also 0 Stunden und dann 3 Stunden vorher, 6 Stunden, 12 Stunden und so weiter, immer in 3, 6, 12 Stunden Rhythmus. Hinter dem, wie viel Daten man haben will, kann man dann sagen.
Und das ist immer nur aktuell oder ist das eine Voraussage?
Das ist eine Voraussage.
Für welchen Zeitraum?
Die wird gerechnet mit einem relativ guten Akkuratest, glaube ich, so um 3, 4, 5 Tage. Es ist ganz gut. Und danach wird es ein bisschen mehr wie Kaffeesatz lesen.
Also ganz gut im Sinne von, so kommt es dann meistens auch.
Ja.
Das heißt, während du mit deiner Nussschale da, mit deiner überdimensionierten irgendwo mitten auf dem Atlantik, auf dem Ozean rum schipperst, empfängst du das über Kurzwelle. Kurzwelle geht einfach around the globe sozusagen.
Durch das Reflexionsmechanismus an die Ironosphäre kannst du sehr weit funken damit. Also ich kann zum Beispiel ohne Probleme über 2-3.000 Meilen Entfernung von der Bade-Station empfangen.
Das heißt von Deutschland aus Seemeilen meistens?
Seemeilen. Ich habe also schon gute Verbindungen gehabt mit Entfernung von 2-3.000 Meilen.
Das heißt, das reicht auf jeden Fall von der Karibik bis nach Deutschland?
Nicht ganz. Von der Karibik benutze ich meistens nordamerikanische Stationen. Letzte Zeit habe ich hier häufig verwendet in Daytona, Florida oder in North Carolina. Ich benutze da so einen Dienst, die nennt sich Sail Mail Association. Die betreiben etliche von diesen...
Das ist noch ein bisschen langsamer als Sail Mail.
Wenn man Amateurfunka ist, gibt es natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, direkt über die Basis der Amateurfunka das zu machen. Aber ich habe nie diese komplette Amateurfunk-Lizenz gemacht, also mit Radio-Basteln und so weiter.
Verstehe.
Deswegen nutze ich da die kommerzielle Variante, wo man dann jährlich einen Obolus bezahlt. Und dann kann man da funken.
Kurzwelle ist die einzige Möglichkeit, interaktiv mit der Außenwelt permanent in Verbindung zu bleiben.
Es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten, zum Beispiel Satellitentelefon.
Hast du auch?
Ja, ich habe auch ein Satellitentelefon. Aber ein Iridium-Satellitentelefon, ein Motorola-Teil. Es gibt da zwei wesentliche Systeme, die interessant sind, die weltweit funktionieren. Das wäre also Inmarsat oder Iridium. Wobei Inmarsat hohe geostationäre Satelliten sind, mit dem entsprechend größeren, eher Attaché-Koffer-großen Antennen, die man braucht, um mit den Satelliten zu kommunizieren. Das Iridium war damals, als ich losgefahren bin, das attraktivste Ding, was also weltweit funktioniert und was also noch eher so Hundeknochengröße hat. Nicht mal so richtig wie Handy, aber Hundeknochengröße.
Ja, so wie die ersten Mobilfunktelefone sozusagen.
Genau, ja.
Die Pockys.
Es gibt kleinere Mobilfunktelefone, also Satellitentelefone, die aber regional nur funktionieren. Zum Beispiel die Toraia in Mittleren Osten bis Indien. Die sind sehr gut, die sind also handygroß. Aber die funktionieren halt nur in diesem Netz. Und da gibt es dann auch in amerikanischen Netzen Satellitentelefone, die funktionieren nur auf dem nord- und südamerikanischen Kontinent. Ich wollte eins mit weltweiter Abdeckung, und da war Iridium für mich das Attraktivste.
Und das läuft auch zuverlässig.
Das läuft recht zuverlässig. Es gibt schon mal gelinke ich mal einen Aussetzer. Wenn du da guckst, musst du schon gucken, wie die Fälter gerade in dem Grenzbereich von einem Satelliten zum nächsten Satelliten sind. Das ist Handover. Dann machen wir mal einen kurzen Aussetzer.
Aber du kannst da schon direkt Telefonnummern anrufen. Du kannst mich auf mein Mobiltelefon anrufen.
Ich kann dich auf dein Mobiltelefonnummer anrufen, und ich kann liebe Telefonnummern wählen.
Aber wenn du angerufen wirst, dann kostet das auch Geld?
Nee, das kostet mich kein Geld. Und das ist sogar relativ günstig. Also ich bezahle momentan die aktuelle, in Florida gekaufte SIM-Karte. Ich hatte früher eine Prepaid-SIM-Karte, aber das sind ja Räuber. Das ist noch das amerikanische Prinzip. Da verfallen die Minuten noch und so was. Wenn man dann mal eine längere Zeit nicht irgendwie benutzt, dann, wenn man zu sehr in der Nähe vom Land ist, dann verfallen die Minuten, die SIM-Karte verfällt und dergleichen. Das sind echt echte Raubpiraten dann noch. Bei uns ist ja verfallene Minuten gar nicht mehr üblich. Aber naja, bei denen ist das noch so. Und da muss man sehr aufpassen. Habe ich den jetzt also in der günstigen, monatlichen Kontakt genommen aus Florida. Selber iridium, Netz, aber eben halt ein anderer Anbieter, der die SIM-Karten dann verteilt.
Günstig ist in?
1,09 Dollar die Minute überall in die Welt.
Muss man da monatlich noch was abplatzen?
Was war das gewesen? 17 oder 27 Dollar.
Okay, also alles nicht so wild.
Und dann 1,09 Dollar die Minute. Inbeliebige Netze, wenn ich anrufe. Wenn du allerdings von deinem Vodafone oder Telekom-Handy das anrufst, das kann schon mal 4 bis 7 oder 8 Euro die Minute werden. Das sind ja diese Länderkennungen, die so ganz exotisch aussehen. Also diese Satellitentelefon-Anbieter haben ihre eigenen Länderkennungen. Plus 88 irgendwas oder so für das Regium. Wenn du die anrufst, das saugt dir das, die Börse leer, wie nichts Gutes. Also ganz schnell.
Plus 88 ist 16 und 17.
Genau. Und das ist natürlich eine Möglichkeit, wie du dir jemandem telefonieren kannst, wenn du wirklich in einer Notsituation hast. Denk mal zum Beispiel an, dass du einen medizinischen Notfall anbohrst. Dann gibt es einen Dienst von einem Krankenhaus hier in Cuxhaven. Die bieten Medico-Gespräche an, also medizinische Beratungsgespräche für Leute, die mit einem Satellitentelefon anrufen. von einem Boot aus und du musst also irgendwas Wichtiges mit denen abklären. Du hast eben keinen Arzt an Bord und du musst halt irgendwie Konversationen haben.
Allergische Reaktionen.
Und dann kannst du die direkt anrufen und kannst also mit solchen Notfallsituationen noch irgendwie Hilfe bekommen. Oder du hast ein ganz irres technisches Problem und brauchst einen Spezialisten und kannst den direkt am Schreibtisch anrufen und den wirklich fragen, wie mache ich denn das? Ich habe diese und diese Teile zur Verfügung. Wie kriege ich das noch so wieder gebogen, dass es wieder tut? Für solche Zwecke ist ein Satellitentelefon sehr gut.
Ganz hilfreich.
Ja, hilfreich.
Aber Kurzwelle gibt es das nicht so.
Nee, weil man kann im Wesentlichen ja nicht sprechen, weil du musst ja jemanden haben, eine Küstenfunkschelle, wo jemand am Telefon sozusagen am Ding lauscht und dann deinen Ruf aufnimmt. Du rufst ihn und rufst ihn und er nimmt nicht ab oder so. Also da gibt es dann ja... Funken ist in dem Sinne ja nicht so zuverlässig. Also ich habe mich so, im Wesentlichen Kurzwelle benutze ich im Wesentlichen für E-Mail und Kurzwellen-Faxe. Gelegentlich gibt es auch solche Kurzwellen-Funkrunden, die dann so abgehalten werden, wo dann irgendwelche Leute so eine Art Diskussionsthema sozusagen zu bestimmten Zeit jeden Tag machen, wo man das dann treffen kann. Oder wenn es so eine karibische Runde gibt, wo karibisches Wetter und karibische Security diskutiert wird und solche Sachen.
Oder Chatroom sozusagen.
Kurzwellen-Chatrooms, die dann so stattfinden. Das ist ganz nett.
Und gibt es Internet irgendwie auf dem Atlantik?
Über Satellitentelefone dann.
Über das Iridium?
Über Iridium. Grotten langsam.
Das ist in?
2400 Boot.
Das ist ja wie früher.
Ja klar. Das ist grottenlangsam.
Ja, in der Geschwindigkeit habe ich seinerzeit mal das Usenet irgendwie aus deinem Computer herausgeholt. Lang ist's her.
Lang ist's her. Aber das ist über Satellitentelefone noch so was, was heute tagüblich ist. 9600 kann man auch schon bekommen, in moderneren Satellitentelefonen, manchen Netzen.
Ja, ich will sagen, mit 2400 kann man schon mitarbeiten, wenn man jetzt nicht sich die ganze Zeit Browser-Updates runterladen möchte oder so was.
Für Notfall ist es mal ganz adäquat. Da ist die Funktion des Abschalten der Bilder noch wirklich gefordert. Ist es noch nichts, also dieser Schalter müssen wir nicht aus dem Browser entfernen.
Ich glaube, mein Browser hat diesen Schalter noch gar nicht, aber den kann man wahrscheinlich nachrüsten. Naja, auf jeden Fall denkt man dann wieder mal über die Effizienz von Kompressionsalgorithmen nach, etc. Und ist das dann auch irgendwie teuer?
Nach Minutenpreisen. Das ist eine ganz normale Verbindung nach Minutenpreisen. Da bezahlt sie die ganze Zeit einen Dollar neun die Minute.
Ach so, es gibt keinen Paketdienst auf ihrem Medium?
Es ist ein Paketdienst, aber das wird auch als Telefongespräch gewertet.
Das heißt, ich muss quasi mit so einer Verbindung aufbauen und die Verbindung... Mit so einer virtuellen Paketgegenstelle, wo ich dann sozusagen das Netz hin habe.
Genau, dann rufst du also die Gegenstelle, die Basistation, bei denen irgendwo in Houston, Texas oder in Austin, Texas sitzen die, die Basistation für Iridium. Und die rufst du an in einer speziellen Telefonnummer im Iridium-Netz und dann hast du eine Verbindung und dann hast du Pakete über das Iridium-Netz. Aber das ist eigentlich eher so wie HSCD auf dem... Auf GSM, ja.
Und wie interfässt du da in deinen Computer rein, wenn du das brauchst?
Ein Kabel, ganz klassisch, ein krabelserielles Kabel.
Das heißt, du machst da nochmal PPP drüber oder was?
So modern sind diese Telefonnummer.
Das macht ja auch noch die DSL-Leitung, machen das ja auch heute noch. Von daher ist ja alles wie zu Hause.
Und dann brauchst du halt, weil ein moderner Laptop ja keinen seriellen hat, brauchst du dann immer den USB-seriellen Adapter noch dazu, als Equipment.
Aber es geht.
Aber den brauchst du ja auch, um die Bootstarten zu bekommen.
Aber ich hab neulich so ein Video gesehen, wo tatsächlich echt schnelles Netz mitten auf dem Pazifik am Start war. Was ist denn das für ein Dienst gewesen?
Das sind andere Dienste.
Der hat ein Bildtelefon drüber gemacht.
Kannste machen. Du kriegst alles. Du kriegst auch, wenn du willst, über Satelliten strecken, kannst du dir auch Bandbreiten in den Megabit-Bereich bekommen. Aber das ist natürlich auch noch teuer. Das ist richtig teuer. Erstens mal brauchst du eine selbst nachführende Antenne. Eine Antenne, die die Bootslegungen ausgleicht, die hoch montiert ist, die sich ständig reguliert. Die Schüssel, die kleine Schüssel.
Jede Welle.
Jede Welle ausgleicht und dann zu dem Satelliten hin zeigt, wenn es ein geostationärer Satellit ist, die dann die Konklusion rüber macht. Und dann die Abos darüber, die monatlichen, das bewegt sich dann, der wird dann kräftig aus seinem Portemonnaie gezogen. Also ich kann mich in den Sinn, einfach zu Gelegenheitsbrausen im Internet gucken, was kostet sowas. Ich glaube, die Installation beginnt so bei 10.000 bis 15.000 aufwärts für die Hardware, die man sich bauen, einbauen lassen muss. Und die Monats-Abo sind auch nicht unter 1.000 bis 2.000. Aber dafür könnte es natürlich dann aber auch skypen mitten im... Aber da will man nicht mal skypen, da hat man sowieso sein Gespräch drinnen.
Ich habe ein Video gesehen, wo irgendjemand wirklich auf so einem schnellfahrenden Boot mit seinem iPhone, also dieses, was auch immer das Internet gemacht hat, hat dann so einen Vedern aufgemacht und dann hat er halt da irgendwie mit Facetime...
Ist Standard, ist Standard...
.einen iPhone da irgendwie...
Ist Standard, also die großen Yachten, die Luxus-Yachten haben es so verstanden. Du siehst ja an den Yachten, an den ganzen Trägern, die die oben drauf haben, etliche von den Schüsseln, also diese großen Super-Yachten, da findest du mal drei, vier Schüsseln drauf oder so. Da haben die eine für Telefon, eine für Satelliten-TV und noch eine für, was sehe ich hier, irgendwas, für Internet und noch eine als Ersatz. Die haben also da etliche drauf, häufig mal eine Menge.
Das ist ja mal ein Argument für so eine richtige Luxus-Jacht. Wozu braucht man das eigentlich? Aber das ist natürlich schon cool, wenn man da irgendwie... Oder ist das nicht irgendwie schon wieder langweilig? Ist man nicht ganz froh, dass man nochmal kein Internet hat?
Ist ganz schön, wenn man mal vollkommen ab ist von allem. Also was man natürlich immer braucht, gerade als Segler, ist die Wetterberichte. Da musst du immer darauf achten, dass du da akkurat informiert bist. Oder für Notfälle, dass man auch was absetzen kann. Deswegen auch bei mir diese zweigleisige Fahrt. Ich habe also zwei Weitkommunikationsmittel an Bord. Iridium-Telefon und Satellitentelefon, falls eins von beiden ausfällt. Satellitentelefon, Iridium und Kurzwelle. Falls eins von beiden ausfällt, hat man noch ein zweites, über ein ganz anderes Medium. Also noch mal bei Notfällen kommunizieren kann.
Was du ja auch noch an Bord hast, ist ja auch schon ein paarmal gefallen, ist ja irgendwie auch schon fast so selbstverständlich, ist GPS.
Ja, GPS gehört immer dazu. Mehrere.
Muss man schon gar nicht mehr drüber reden, aber ist das?
Ja, du brauchst ja mehrere GPS-Geräte, falls eins ausfällt. Momentan sind es vier.
Vier?
Vier GPS.
Du hast nur vier, weil du...
Zufällig jetzt war so alles sicher in Begebenheit. Man hat zum Beispiel im iPhone ein GPS mit drin.
Ach so, verstehe. Du hast einfach mal alles zusammengezählt.
Ja, also im Wesentlichen ist es das eingebaute Boots-GPS und noch ein Handheld-GPS, klassisch, und dann diverses, irgendwie ein Telefon, so kommt es auf vier.
Hast du die mal miteinander so verglichen, ob die eigentlich auch mal dasselbe anzeigen?
Kommt ziemlich gut hin, bis auf die Tatsache, dass die billigeren Geräte mehr Ausweicher, also Aussetzer haben. Das nennt sich ja bei GPS die Horizontal und Vertical Delusion of Precision. Also wie die Streuung ist, um den wirklichen Ort drum herum. Und die billigeren GPS haben einfach eine größere Streuung. Da kommt man so ausreißend zwischendurch, wo du mal so ein bisschen ab bist. Da muss man über größere Zeiten mitteln, um die wirkliche Position rauszubekommen.
Das heißt, so ein Mobiltelefon, so ein iPhone, ist da nicht so akkurat wie jetzt professionellen.
Was also ganz ärgerlich ist, was mich beim iPhone total ärgert, ist die Tatsache, wenn man in den Flugmodus geht. Dann, weil man jetzt z.B. dem mal anzieht, ich will Strom sparen, weil ich weiß, ich bin mitten am Atlantik. Und ich habe im Flugmodus, ich brauche kein Wi-Fi, weil das Wi-Fi im Modus ausgeschaltet ist. Ich könnte auch eigentlich, brauche auch kein Wi-Fi. Ich habe GSM oder so etwas, oder MTS gibt es sowieso nicht, weil weit weg von allem. Aber ich möchte vielleicht das GPS verwenden. Das geht nicht, weil dieses blöde iPhone, das GPS eigentlich nur ein Empfänger ist, was eigentlich nichts endet. Wer sich das ausgedacht hat, ist wohl auch als Kind gegen die Schleuse geschwommen.
Ich kann dir sagen, wer sich das hat einfallen lassen. Das ist der heilige Steve, der in Cupertino. Da war der Meinung, das braucht man nicht. Keine Ahnung, wie ihre Logik ist. Die machen ja auch dieses A-GPS, wo sie sich dann über die Netzwerke noch Kram holen.
Das ist wohl eine Chip-Geschichte. In dem Sinn ist das GPS ziemlich zusammen mit dem GSM. Zusammen in irgendwie in einem Stein drin. Und die schalten wohl den ganzen Stein ab beim Flugmodus. Das hat wohl was damit zu tun. Das finde ich aber total bescheuert. Als Segler so.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist blöd. Ja, nicht nur als Segler. Ich meine, das ist ja auch was, was ich auf dem Berg, wenn man mit einer Offline-Karte arbeitet oder so.
Du musst aber immer das GSM anhaben und dann sucht das Ding ständig deinen Provider, der nicht da ist, und dann verbraucht er mehr Strom.
Tja, musst du mal eine Mail schreiben.
An Steve Jobs?
Der Antwort ist ja sogar manchmal.
Können wir mal tun.
Du bist ja eher gerade so ein bisschen am Basteln mit dem iPhone, damit dein Wetter da ist.
Als Diversifikation vom Segeln habe ich mich jetzt nochmal intensiv mit dem iPhone...
Nachdem alle Bücher ausgelesen wurden.
Nein, nicht ganz. Aber um also ein bisschen ab, noch ein bisschen was anderes machen zu können, um wieder ein bisschen mit... Die Finger, die ziehen sich, ich finde, so hingezogen zu den Tasten, man will ja was mit dem Computer machen, nicht nur Segeln, habe ich als Projekt gemacht, um diese Wetterdaten von der NOAA schön grafisch zu visualisieren. Auf einem kleinen, handlichen Telefon habe ich ein bisschen iPhone-Applikationen gebastelt, die diese Informationen abrufen kann, dass man also auf einer Weltkarte einen Rechteck markieren kann, dann da sagen kann, ich möchte verschiedene Ebenen Informationen haben, Luftdruck, Windrichtung, Windstärke, Wellenrichtung, Wellenhöhe, Temperatur, Luftwassertemperatur, Regenwahrscheinlichkeit und dergleichen. Und die kann ich dann abholen und dann über einen Zeitintervall, die man deswegen so vorhersagen, ab jetzt im Rhythmus von sechs Stunden für die nächsten fünf Tage.
Und abholen dann auch über Kurzwelle so? Nein, nein, nein. Ich meine, du kannst ja dann auch das Audio in dein iPhone reinstecken. Da gibt es so verschiedene Programme, die das so machen.
Das mache ich in dem Fall nicht. Das mache ich ganz normal mit meinem Packtormodum und dem Laptop. Aber wenn ich zum Beispiel an Land bin und ich habe zum Beispiel eine GSM-Karte drinne, wo ich gerade meinetwegen ein Volumen gebucht habe oder gleich mal schnell einen Wetterbericht haben will, oder man sitzt zusammen, macht Kaffeetisch-Navigation, sprich, man will gerade einen Plan für die nächsten Tage eine Fahrt und sagt sich so, wie wird denn das besser dann so sein? Kann das nur auf eine Frage kommen? Dann macht man also in der Kneipe einfach kurz sein iPhone auf, holt sich einen Wetterbericht runter und sagt, das ist gut, das geht. Das kann man machen, ne? Also das ist so für diese Takt, das ist sehr schön, man kann schnell mal, egal wo man gerade ist, man hat zum Beispiel gerade Wi-Fi, weil man gerade in einer Strandbar ist, wo sie einen Wi-Fi-Service haben, dann macht man sein Wi-Fi im iPhone an, guckt sich dann die Wetter-Situation an und sagt, das geht.
Dieses autonome Segeln, das ist ja schon so ein bisschen eigentlich so das, was an Space Travel so ein bisschen am nächsten dran ist, oder?
Ja, gewiss.
Man ist erst mal alleine.
Das ist eigentlich nicht so der Fall, weil überall leben ja Leute an Land, so richtig Gebiete zu erschließen, so aller Captain Cook hat man heute nicht mehr, wo niemand wohnt und niemand lebt.
Na gut, aber du hast zumindest so deine Strecken, wo du halt einfach niemanden triffst, weil er einfach Kinder ist.
Genau. Du findest so viele kleine Inseln. Wir waren jetzt zum Beispiel zwei Monate in Kuba. Da gibt es also richtig viele kleine Inseln, wo niemand wirklich ist, wo du einfach einen Anker werfen kannst. Dann tauchst du an deinem Boot runter und kannst zum Beispiel mal einen Hummer rausholen und so. Und grillen und solche Sachen.
In Kuba kann man auch einfach so hinfahren? Ich meine, wie ist denn das so mit den Einreisebestimmungen?
Entsetzlich fürchterlich. Also mit Booten noch schlimmer, als wenn man sonst so eine Urlaub betreibt. Also wenn man mit einem Flieger hinfliegt, ist es einfacher für einen Strandurlaub und dann vielleicht mit einem Mietwagen oder Bus durch diese Insel zu erkunden. Bei Booten sind sie sehr, sehr paranoid, weil das ist ja eine Möglichkeit, um noch jemanden mitzunehmen, der aus dem Land vielleicht rauskönnte. Da sind sie entsetzlich paranoid. Also das ist viel Formularkram.
Aber es geht. Sie lassen einen schon auch mal dahin.
Aber die beschränken einen ziemlich, wo man hin kann und wo man mit seinem Dingy an Land kann. Ich bin also auch schon in einem Ort mal weggeschickt worden von der Gardia Frontera, weil sie mich nicht da haben wollten und so.
Aber das ist jetzt nur in Kuba so Hardcore oder überall so?
Das ist nur in Kuba so Hardcore. Also Kuba ist da ja wie die DDR damals sozusagen. Und die haben ihre Mauer. Die Leute dürfen nicht frei reisen. Und weil es halt eine Insel ist, sind natürlich Boote generell verdächtig. Generell von vornherein. Das bedeutet also auch nur speziell ausgesuchte Leute, Kubaner selber, sind in der Lage, ein Boot zu benutzen. Denn normale Kubaner darf nicht auf ein Boot. Also das sind wirklich ausgesuchte Leute. Und auch die Fischer, die also selber Boote betreiben, das sind regime-treue und feste Leute, die nicht abhauen.
Verstehe. Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, wenn man da jetzt so als Luxustourist da mit seiner Minijacht da angeschwommen kommt, dann ist man natürlich potenziell erst mal so ein Fluchthelfer.
Genau. Man ist also potenziell erst mal sowieso verdächtig.
Aber sie haben dich trotzdem reingelassen.
Ja, das machen sie schon. Die wollen ja auch von Tourismus leben, die wollen auch ein bisschen Geld verdienen. Die Annahme ist natürlich auch, dass Touristen die ganzen auch ein bisschen Geld ausgeben und vielleicht ein bisschen Wirtschaft ins Land bringen. Also es ist ein Zielspalt. Am liebsten würden sie uns wegschicken, aber sie können es eigentlich nicht, weil sie das Geld brauchen.
Haben wir denn jetzt so die... Ich will ja nichts vergessen hier, das ist ja so spannend. Die Technik auf deinem Boot, haben wir das irgendwie jetzt alles abgeklappert?
Was noch ganz wichtig ist, was man braucht, wenn man in Landen hier ist, ist eine gute Wi-Fi-Antenne. Eine richtig gute.
Um überall mal nagen zu können.
Genau. Man braucht zum Beispiel, also was wir an Bord haben, ist so ein kleiner Router, ein lokales Netzwerk, was unser eigenes Wi-Fi-Netz ist an Bord. Und dann ist ja nicht eine Auto-Antenne, die man zum Beispiel an einem Haljad, an einem Seil, an einem Fall nach oben ziehen kann, in den Mast ein bisschen, so auf etwas höheren, erhöhten Niveau. Und dass die auch Auto ist, also sprich, die also nicht kaputt geht, wenn man in den Regenschauer runterkommt. Also eine Auto-Antenne. Outdoor-Antenne. Die man dann einstellen kann auf das gewünschte Drahtlos-Netzwerk. Meistens haben die so ein webbasiertes Interface, das man da sozusagen einstellen kann, auf welchem Netz soll sie sich einloggen. Und dann hat man da so einen kleinen Router-Konzept ab. Und man hat dann ein eigenes kleines lokales Wi-Fi-Netz, wo man seine iPhones mit bedienen kann, seine Laptops mit bedienen kann. Und die große Wi-Fi-Antenne hat die große Reichweite, die sind meistens auch mit etwas mehr Sendeleistung versehen.
Und die klingt sich dann in alles ein, was irgendwie nicht genug Passwörter hat.
Oder was man zum Beispiel hat, was ja auch möglich ist. Man hat ja manchmal so einen Jachtclub, wo man dann so einen Service bieten kann, dass sie ein Wi-Fi-Netz anbieten, wo man das dann so ganz machen kann.
Wie weit reicht denn seine Antenne so?
Oh, die reicht weit. Die reicht nicht weit. Das ist eine 1 Watt Sendeleistungsantenne. Normalerweise sind es, glaube ich, nur 200 mW bei Wi-Fi erlaubt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, aber nicht so viel auf jeden Fall.
1 Watt und das ist eine große 9 dB oder 12 dB Antenne. Wenn ich die hochziehe auf erhöhtem Level, ich kann schon so über so ein einfaches Hausnetz, was frei ist, kann ich schon aus 3-4 Kilometer Entfernung.
3-4 Kilometer?
Ja, kann ich das mit...
boah...
verwenden. Krass. Man sieht eine Menge Wi-Fi Netze, wenn man die Antenne hochzieht.
Kann ich mir vorstellen. Hast du auch schon das passende Skript gebaut, was dann alle Standardpasswörter durchklickt?
Nee, das habe ich nicht gemacht, aber man könnte es theoretisch machen. Auf dieser Antenne läuft selber ein Linux drauf.
Auf der Antenne?
Ja, das ist ein kleiner Router, ein MIPS-basierter Router. ROS.
ROS?
Das ist also so ein Ubiquiti-Networks, so heißen die in Amerika. Die bieten das her. Ubient oder wie heißen die?
Ubiquiti-Networks.
Genau. Und die bieten also schöne Antennen an, so Auto-Antennen mit Linux drauf. Und die zieht man sich dann so um sein Mast hoch und die machen dann die Internet-Anbindung.
Verstehe. Air Max.
Genau. Ich habe in dem Fall eine Bullet HP2-Antenne. Also die Air Max sind eher die Provider-Geschichten. Ich bin eine größere Fläche abdecken will mit Wi-Fi. Ich habe so eine Bullet HP2-Antenne.
Bullet M sehe ich hier. Vielleicht gibt es die nicht mehr.
Gibt es zwei Klassen. Nicht mehr eine mit Air Max und andere. Es gibt da verschiedene Klassen dort von Produkten. Nicht Air Max, es gibt zwei andere Klassen. Ganz vorne. Bullet HP2 oder so heißt das. Das ist ein ganz gutes kleines Gerät. Das ist nicht teuer. Kostet nur so einen Bereich von 100, 200 Dollar.
Okay, finde ich jetzt hier gerade nicht.
Aber...
Was nie alles gibt.
Ja, das ist eine essentielle Sache. Man zieht das hoch. Strandbar, die bieten heutzutage auch gerne mal Wi-Fi an. Und wenn du da vorne vorankerst, hast du gleich Internet.
Kann man gleich saugen.
Nein, nicht saugen, aber E-Mail machen. Zum Beispiel mit irgendwelchen Leuten Kontakt treten. Skype mal irgendwo daheim anrufen. Also unter Seglern ist also Skype das Standardmittel, um in Kontakt zu bleiben. Das ist ganz definitiv so.
Na, das macht ja auch total Sinn, ne? Presence und so weiter. Da sieht man auch gleich, ob die Leute online sind und wo. Genau. Wo sie sind, sieht man natürlich nur, wenn sie es sagen. Aber das sagen sie ja wahrscheinlich.
Ja, die meisten sagen es, genau.
Aber jetzt haben wir die Technik durch. Wie, ähm, wir können ja vielleicht nochmal so ein bisschen auf das, ähm, so auf das Leben, auf ein Boot nochmal so zurückkommen, wo wir irgendwie angefangen haben. Ähm, erinnert sich da irgendwas?
Ja, es ist...
Wenn man so einen Blickwinkel da permanent einnimmt.
Erinnert sich sehr viel. Man kann mit vielen Dingen im normalen hektischen Leben so in der Stadt nicht so viel anfangen. Das ist gewöhnungsbedürftig. Der Lebenszyklus ist ein anderer, wenn man so an Bord Sachen macht. Und es geht, bewegt sich alles sehr langsam und angenehm. Und es ist, ähm, eine Lebensart, die ich sehr genieße. Man muss natürlich viel Zeit haben. Es geht alles nicht schnell. Die Bewegung ist langsam. Man bewegt sich langsam vorwärts. Man wird ja auch gehindert von der Natur. Man kann nicht immer dorthin, wo man gerade hin will. Man muss also das nehmen, was man gerade kriegt, was Mutter Natur einem an Wetter schickt. Und man bewegt sich aber sehr langsam. Und es ist eine sehr nette Community von Leuten, die das selbe machen. Wenn man zum Beispiel irgendwo in der Bucht ist oder einen Anker fallen lässt, ist es also ein leichtes Kontakt zu bekommen. Es ist also nicht so wie in anderen Communities, wo man erst langsam reinkommen muss. Es ist eine sehr offene und einfach reinkommende Gemeinschaft von Leuten. Man fährt mit dem Dinghy in der Bucht und klopft in ein anderes Boot und kommt sofort ins Gespräch. Ein Dinghy ist ein Gummiboot. Es ist ein kleines Beiboot, was man ja jedes Boot braucht. Wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Anker werfe, irgendwo in der Bucht, dann ist das Boot erst mal stationär mit Anker, ist meine Basispunkt. Dann habe ich ein Schlauchboot, ein kleines mit einem kleinen Außenbordmotor. Wenn ich mich dann an Land komme, zum Beispiel Einkäufe erledige, an Land gehe und dergleichen.
Das Fahrrad sozusagen.
Genau. Neben dem Klapprad, das man auch noch an Bord hat.
Das kommt dann aufs Dinghy?
Genau, dann an Land und dann Fahrrad durch die Gegend.
So ein Mantrosch-Car-System von verschiedenen Transportmöglichkeiten. Noch ein Rucksack mit Inlandskates, und dann hast du alles zusammen.
Man kommt mit den Leuten relativ schnell in guten Kontakt. Es ergeben sich manchmal so Flottilien von mehreren Booten, die längere Zeit zusammen eine Strecke bewältigen und dann immer wieder zwischendurch segeln und dann wieder im Hafen zusammenkommen, mit denen man dann zusammen, was weiß ich, gemeinsam lebt de facto eine Weile lang. Man ist dann die tagsüber, wenn man irgendwo segelt, getrennt zwar auf getrennten Booten. Dann abends trifft man sich auf einem Boot, macht Party, grillt.
Zugvögel sozusagen, für kurze Zeit.
Ja, wie Zugvögel. Ich habe dann also gehört, in Amerika, wir sind eine Weile lang in Nordamerika gesegelt, da gibt es dann eine Klasse von diesen Seglern, die nennen die Snowbirds. Ich meine jetzt nicht die Snowbirds mit dem weißen Pulver und deren Schnupfen. Da gibt es dann auch nochmal so ein Wort, das die Amerikaner haben für manche Leute. Ich meine die Snowbirds, die meistens im Winter aus dem Norden Amerikas fliehen und Richtung Florida segeln. Und dann im Sommer wieder nach Norden, weil sie dann das schöne Wetter in Nördchen gefilmt haben.
Verstehe, also so richtige Zugvögel.
Richtige Zugvögel, die wirklich jährlich hin und her segeln. Und dann im Sommer weit südlich sind und im Sommer dann im Norden. In den Snowbirds. Und in Amerika gibt es gerade diesen Intercoursel Waterway. Das ist ein Weg, wo man nicht im Atlantik segeln muss und nicht im Atlantik sein muss. Und also vielfach durch Kanäle, nahezu von New York bis Florida, komplett in Land auf dem Kanal und Flusssystem runterkommen kann, hochkommen kann, ohne die wirklich im offenen Meer sein zu müssen. Wo viele solche kleinere Boote einfach den Weg im Tageshop-Verfahren von Marina zu Marina in den Süden machen können oder im Norden. Nennt sich Intercoursel oder Intracoursel. Intracoursel.
Es gibt sogar zwei.
Der Golf ist aber nur kurz, weil der ist ja sozusagen auf der Seite von Florida hoch nach Texas. Und der Weg aber von Florida hoch bis fast nach New York. Du kannst fast durchgehen.
4.800 Kilometer. Krass. Auch nett.
Und da gibt es halt die Snowbirds dann. Das ist auch eine Community, wenn man da eine Weile lang mitmacht. Das haben wir gemacht. Wir sind von Norfolk bis runter nach North Carolina. Ich hab's vergessen. Wir sind im Intracoursel Waterway gefahren. Nicht im Atlantik, wie sonst üblich. Und da haben wir auch einige Leute kennengelernt, die das so immer ständig machen. Und das ist auch eine nette Gemeinschaft.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen entspannter, wenn man nicht die ganze Zeit den Hochsee-Bedingungen ausgesetzt ist.
Ja, es ist wesentlich entspannter. Man macht dann aber eigentlich nur Tagestouren. Man hat keinen Autopiloten. Man muss ja alles steuern. Also alles Kanalfahrt oder kleine Flüsse oder ein bisschen ein engeres Gebiet.
Versteht man ganz anderen Konzentrationsbedarf auch.
Genau, da muss man immer selbst steuern. Man hat also keinen Autopilot im Endeffekt. Man fährt ja so vielfach in diesen Tonnenstrichen, also zwischen roten und grünen Tonnen hin und her. Um also den Weg, der ausgebaggert ist, genau zu folgen. Sonst läuft man auf Sand. Ist ja so eine Art Wattenmeer im Umgebung, wo also richtig flach ist. Und man kann also schnell auf Sand laufen. Und da muss man schon aufpassen. Aber was wichtig ist, ist die Community von den Leuten. Die sind relativ gut. Man trifft immer dieselben Leute wieder. Und das macht die Sache auch ein bisschen aus. Manchmal bleibt man in einem Ort ein bisschen länger. Wir waren zum Beispiel zwei Monate in der selben Bucht drin. Deswegen war man gute Leute dort kennengelernt.
Was bleibt denn für dich jetzt noch so geek-technisch zu machen? Was ist denn so der Next Frontier?
Also der Next Frontier ist der Austausch meiner ganzen Seat-Hog-Equipments. Also das, was ich vorhin erwähnt habe, die meisten Sensoren, die ich habe, die aktuell mit diesem etwas älteren Seat-Hog-Mechanismus angeschlossen sind, müssen ersetzt werden. Das ist jetzt durch einen Schaden. Ich habe also das Problem gehabt, dass sich ein statischen Überschlag von einem Blitz bei mir im Mast eingeschlagen ist, der langsam aber sicher alle Geräte zum Ausfall bringt. Die Statik, die reingekommen ist, hat die meisten Geräte in so einer Art progressiven Ausfall-Serie. Die fallen so um die Domino-Steine jetzt langsam.
Das heißt, sie haben einmal was abgekriegt, aber die sterben alle nicht sofort.
Nein, die sterben nicht sofort. Ein Gerät war sofort weg, das war der Windmesser. Das wurde oben in den Windmesser eingeschlagen, der oben am Mast-Topf befestigt ist. Die Statik hat sich dann runterbewegt über dieses Bus-System in alle Geräte.
Hast du denn da überhaupt einen Blitz-Ableiter dran?
Nein. Es gibt da so zwei Religionen. Das ist so fast wie iVersus eMax. Ob man große Grundplatten mit Erdung macht, oder ob man das nicht tut, oder ob man nagt einfach, man ist in einer Plastikhülle und man hofft, dass es isoliert genug ist. Ich bin nicht ganz über den Plan, was das Bessere ist. Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber du bist jetzt in der Plastikhülle.
Ich bin momentan in der isolierten Plastikhülle, Fraktion ohne große Erdung. Weil im Endeffekt, wenn diese großen Energiemengen in einen Mast einschlagen, dann geht es auch wieder statiküber auf Funkgeräte oder auf Sensorikleitungen, wie dieses CTOC-System. Ich bin mir nicht so im Plan, wie man das komplett verhindern kann.
Verstehe. Und was willst du dann machen? Also du baust den ganzen Tag und gehst dann auf Ethernet oder was?
Mal schauen. Ich muss mal schauen, was meine Versicherung sagt, ob ich jetzt sowas bekomme.
Verstehe.
Und wenn dann der Scheck groß genug ist von der Versicherung, dann kann ich mir vielleicht was leisten, was ich sagen kann. CTOC-NG mit Ethernet-Basierend.
Und sowas, was die Kommunikation, die Außenwelt, die Internetoptionen betrifft?
Es gibt langsam aber sicher bessere, schönere Tarife und Möglichkeiten über Idiom und Inmarsat, die so bis 64kbit die Endgeschwindigkeit zu erträglichen Preisen vielleicht ermöglichen. Das wäre eine Möglichkeit da nochmal nachzulegen.
Da könnte man dann schon über ganz interessante Anwendungen nachdenken. Fällt dir was ein? Oder willst du eigentlich in Ruhe gelassen werden von dem Internet?
Eigentlich in Ruhe gelassen werden, aber ich weiß, ich brauche alte Informationen auch. Im Wesentlichen ist es die Kommunikation des Internets, also die Kommunikationsfeatures. Es ist ganz schön, wenn man zwischendurch Twittern kann.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber ich denke mir, was weiß ich? Wenn man jetzt so viele Leute kennenlernt über die Jahre, wenn man sich jeden von denen, wie bei Google Latitude, einen Friend-basierten Location-Dienst hat und dann so halbwegs realtime-mäßig die Position bestimmen kann, kann einem das Tool ja sozusagen vorschlagen, wenn du jetzt, so wie die Winde stehen, hier nochmal einen Schlenker machst über die Insel, dann könnte da noch ein gekühltes Bier mit drei Freunden auf dich warten.
Das wäre natürlich eine gute Sache. Das wäre wirklich cool. Weil wir machen das ja momentan über Funk, über E-Mails und so etwas.
Das sind die maximal fortgeschrittenste Dekadenz, die ich mir so vorstellen könnte. Aber das ist ja eigentlich immer die beste Motivation für solche Anwendungen.
Dieser Location-based Service, wo die ganzen Segler sind, wäre definitiv sehr interessant. Das würde mich ja schon faszinieren, sowas.
Vielleicht kommen wir ja irgendwann nochmal zusammen und machen hier Segeln Revisited. Aber das soll jetzt erst mal reichen, würde ich sagen.
Genau, danke.
Wenn wir nicht was ganz dramatisch Wichtiges vergessen haben, fällt dir irgendwas ein? Irgendeine wichtige Botschaft?
Ja, das ist eine gute Möglichkeit, dich vollkommen von der normalen Alltagswelt abzuschotten. Man ist in Anspruch genommen. Von der Planung her, man muss mit Wetter planen, man muss die Logistik machen, man muss einkaufen. Wenn man also mal auf die schnelle Art und Weise seinen Alltag vergessen will, segeln ist ein guter Weg dazu. Man wird vollkommen in Anspruch genommen von den ganzen Tätigkeiten und vergisst den Alltag am schnellsten. Das ist so mein Fazit davon.
Kommt sozusagen gleich nach Podcasting. Ich habe den Alltag jetzt auch vergessen. Das war super. Mal wieder eine Reise ganz woanders hin. Das mag ich immer am liebsten. Mit Geekfaktor. Ja, und dann klappt man ja auch mal die Rechner zu. Ist ja auch schon fortgeschritten hier die Sendung. Ja, und insofern vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Chaosradio Express, ihr wisst, es geht immer weiter. Und das war die 166. Und die 167, die kommt sicherlich auch bald. Und vielen Dank und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.
Und dann beim Abendbrot, mach ich beim Abendbrot, auf unserem Siegelboot, für meinen Süßen und für mich. Am Sonntag will mein Süßer mit mir stiegen gehen, so fern die Wiene wehen, das wär doch schön.